what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the free game
[Applause]
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my videos and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
wait sorry sorry
um so important announcement this is our
very last show in this apartment as we
are moving
[Music]
it's a little sentimental because you
know this is where we started everything
but we're on to bigger and better things
uh this apartment is kind of trashed I'm
not even gonna lie from other people in
and out of here the last six months so I
I am um yeah we're on the bigger and
better things on top of that we have a
new clips channel so
um if you guys you know uh don't you
know want a little bit less content but
you want just to see like little Clips
here and there go subscribe to our Clips
Channel we're at 25 000 Subs in like two
weeks which is nuts but our goal is to
get 50 by the end of the month so go
subscribe to that the link is in the
description on top of that we have four
membership tiers so the first tier means
that you can be a part of the live chat
during the show the second tier is you
get to see our Vlogs and the last Vlog
that's coming the Vlog that's coming out
this week you get see me rapping I know
none of y'all believe me none of y'all
believe me I can freestyle I can a
little bit a little bit and then you
also get to see the first look at the
behind the scenes footage of us moving
into the penthouse so if you're curious
what a penthouse looks like in London
um let's um you know to be fair
in Texas it'd probably just be an
apartment
but we're in London here
um all right tier three means you get to
connect with us on social media and tier
four means you get a one-on-one call
with me once a month so if you want to
sign up for any of those the link is in
um not in the description but it's in
the um it's like a pinned comment at the
top on top of that go follow my
Instagram just.pearly things guys
funniest thing happened to me this week
so they banned me off Tick Tock sad and
um yeah I'm still going viral on Tick
Tock even though they took away my
account
um because someone else is posting a
clip of me and all of these whales are
like spamming my Instagram right now so
if you want to go you know check out
what they're saying in the comments
they're
yeah they're they're angry but go follow
my Instagram just.pirly things also
um our member of the week is ATA he has
been very active in the chat so we
selected him as a member of the week and
if you want to get on the show DM Eddie
the link is in the description to his
Instagram
so oh but only if you're in London I
know a lot of y'all will like message
and be like I want to come on I'm like
you're you're not in London so yeah you
have him if you're in London okay so um
today we have a lovely panel so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact it can either be about
yourself or just a random fun fact
all right my name is samjee
um
I uh I'm 19 believe it or not
um I'm single and a fun fact about me is
I was recently in the US doing
stagecraft which is building sets for
musical theaters
okay my name's Sam also I'm 28 years old
um I'm from North London
uh with a fun fact oh sorry relationship
says I've got to show you I've got a
shorty and uh fun fact I'm in the
process of uh building a tanning salon
oh that's cool hi everyone my name is V
I am a CIS female getting it right for
the um you know the community
um I am single I'm 34 this year and uh
fun fact I do identify as a banana and I
don't think that it is
offensive
hello everyone I'm Shahara I'm 28. I'm
in a long distance relationship and I
don't know if it's fun but a fact about
me is my motivation for going to law
school was to exclusively advocate for
men in family courts
oh look at let's go yeah
so are you a lawyer now no no so I'll be
studying this oh yeah what motivated you
to do that because I uh kind of
accidentally fell into
um
helps oh I was mainly counseling
somebody who was going through a divorce
um and they just
couldn't they couldn't afford a lawyer
so I was like let me just see what I
could do and I was like I'm actually
really good at this I was combining all
of these uh I was doing all the league
research and kind of getting everything
like looking at his case and seeing you
know what can work and what couldn't and
I was like I'm really good at this I
know and then I also saw what's
happening and you know between the
genders and relations are really bad and
I just think that I mean I've spoken to
a few men and
the perception that they have of women
and the legal system I don't blame them
whatsoever but the perception that they
have women is that
you know the whole mgtow thing can
completely just go in their own way and
excusing women I was like yeah that's
why I want to actually advocate for men
and show them that we're not all like
that yeah no it's it's interesting
um I don't is it so in the U.S
um I know if someone gets divorced and
they have a kid with a girl in certain
States they have to pay 25 percent of
their after-tax income per kid
um I don't think it's as bad here no no
is it similar or no I don't think it's
though it can be similar but I think
what the thing is I think the US is a
bit more Cutthroat yeah yeah in terms of
English law we go by Case by case and
there's more of uh there's a lot more
fairness I think from what I've seen so
far which is good because I mean in
America you have community property
states which are just
like completely just cut the house the
Assets in the middle who cares what
happened in the case yeah and that
that's horrible because some cases are
really unique and they deserve attention
but then you have Equity distribution
states in America some some states and
uh which is what you expect of the Lord
to look at every single case and uh yeah
the the one that I was involved in was
an equitable distribution state
so the fact is the ex-wife actually
didn't fulfill the factors
um so that actually what gained like
that worked in favor of my client what
does fulfill the factors mean so the
statutory factors for he was in the
state of Colorado and in the state of
Colorado you have statutory factors for
example you know I don't know how how
people are going to take this but it is
the factors for example if she wants 50
she will basically get whatever
percentage from the assets if we can uh
like compensate compensating for her
contribution to the marriage if she took
care of children there's a percentage
she gave up things like home making
as opposed to his 50 does that make
sense yeah so she can it could be 70 you
know 20
yeah like that no that's that's really
cool that's really interesting when I
found out about the state I was like
that's brilliant yeah and community
property so it's all really scary like
California is
that's that's the one where I heard this
guy was like going to retire and then he
couldn't retire because he his wife left
him and took the kid to Japan
yeah and like it it's crazy because I
guess in some states like the courts are
separate like the courts for like child
support and the divorce courts so when
he went to child support like to get
child support they would just say oh you
weren't in the kid's life the last six
months but they don't put in the fact
that like she wasn't letting him be yeah
so it's kind of it's very
um especially in the US here I looked up
I I think they get like 13 to like 20
ish per kid if that was correct right is
that yeah I don't know if that's it's
not as Cut Throat I think as the US from
what I learned but that's generally but
again they look at each and every case
which is important because we can't we
can't say it's definitely gonna go this
way differently right right okay sorry
that was just interesting that's why I
asked okay
um so I was gonna say on on a slightly
slightly on a tangent but similar topic
uh fun fact like one of my friends who
studied in law in the UK I actually
asked him about the topic of
um you know like prenups and I said like
you know it must be a good idea right
you're safeguarding yourself you're
safeguarding each person then you feel
like it's a little bit more comfortable
going into the relationship and I said
like surely that's a good way to go you
know in a trusting way and he was like
actually like there are loopholes just
because you have a prenup does not mean
you are going to get away you know
without compensation so
um it might work a little bit better in
America but let's say in the rest of the
world that's that's not the case and
he's like if you're smart especially
like people who have wealth from their
family old family
um they actually like when their kids
get married they actually like they
don't put things or assets under their
children's name for a reason because if
the woman tries to divorce the man and
try to get the assets they can't because
it's under the entire family rather than
under an individual so he was saying
like there are ways
that you can so you can put your
sister's name you can get your brother
so it's like you know like it's it's
it's not yours it's it's the family and
so if that's the way that something's
named then you that that you can kind of
get away with it but you cannot just say
well I've got prenup so this is pre yeah
and that's scary no it scares me it is
and it's hard because I'm very Pro
marriage in like a family sense but I
understand like why guys don't want to
get married you know it like makes sense
because I'm like if I have if I could
possibly lose this much of my assets I
wouldn't want to get married either if
the like the roles were reversed and
what's more terrifying is that you don't
even have to get married to get the same
treatment that's the you can't even
cohabit because it's horrible you can't
even it's like they legally twist their
arm like they say well you know what no
then let's not get married and they say
ah but if you live with her for this
many years it's like
I actually I don't know if anyone is
Canadian in the audience who might know
but actually I heard that in Canada
maybe I might be making this up but I
thought I heard that it doesn't you
don't even have to marry it if you've
been living with your partner for a
certain amount of years that
automatically that person can try and
get money from you I mean I don't I
don't know I don't know I think that's I
think they're that's true but I might be
wrong so if anyone if I'm wrong please
correct me okay I'm sorry sorry no no it
was it's interesting that's okay
um so today we're talking about is the
bar set low for men so the reason
um that I thought of this was because I
was like scrolling through my Tick Tock
and there's this trend going around
where it's like girls will say well the
bar is so low for men and then you know
explain and so I wanted to show you guys
a video-ish if you want to pull it up
um
it's basically a compilation of girls
when they talk about
you know how how low the bar is because
you know between men and women
apparently
you know women are the ones with the low
standards you know men just have the
high standings yeah yeah wait so I I see
that so so the girls are saying on
social media that they have low
standards for men is that what they're
trying to say sort of you'll see in a
second
I'm ready for this one I'm just
so I guess while we're waiting to
represent what we're waiting for ish to
set this up um who do you guys think has
higher standards men or women just off
the bat
women official women women 100 from a
biological standpoint definitely the
girls women
women yeah see this it's interesting
because everyone genuinely agrees here I
could tell I was like this group's gonna
be based
um I think like it's I think it's
important that like we obviously will be
talking about the general trends of
things but then obviously there is
they're outliers right so
um from a biological standpoint it makes
sense that the girls more picky because
you get pregnant you're going to be nine
months your body's gonna get distorted
by the way it's yeah you're never going
to be the same and it's not fun giving
birth so to subject yourself you you
really have to you know really pick
someone whereas a guy you almost can
forget about it that's why women once
when when they um when they ask
questions like why can't we do the same
things as men why can't we sleep around
the same as men the answer is right
there you can get pregnant it's not
complicated I hate that comparison women
go off in the tension but you can do
this so we can do this you clearly can't
because not just that it's also a pair
bonding too like you know if you wanna
um to be more likely to be successful in
marriage then it's on them to
not you know the less partner is the
better sleep around yeah okay you want
to make it full screen the the audience
can see it too right
okay
to be interesting and then they can see
our reaction too yeah
[Laughter]
it's about to get juicy
yes please
um yeah let's go a little to the right
but yeah that's fine
and then just play it and make it full
screen
any prediction Sams do you know what I'm
waiting what do you think wait wait what
do we think what do you think we're
about to see I reckon you're gonna hear
a little [ __ ] right now
delusion yes pure delusion let's do this
and then let me know in the chat if you
guys can tell me about the time when you
realize that the bar is super low for
Matt I was less than 24 hours out from
having my c-section with my son
the hospital was room in baby rooms and
with you I was up all night holding him
and
feeding him because he would not lay in
the bassinet
so while I was up with him wow my now
ex-husband slept on the couch beside me
the whole night the lights were dim in
the morning when my doctor came to check
on my incision
and I said go ahead and turn the lights
on
and he said no let's let him sleep I
have my cell phone and I can use the
flashlight on my cell phone
so my doctor checked my c-section
incision with the
flashlight on his cell phone as to let
my husband continue sleeping
tell me about the time when you realize
that the bar is super low for men
so one time I got rejected by this girl
after our first date like I thought it
went well but apparently it didn't
because she told me you know after I
asked her when she was free again she
said like you know she wasn't into it
and um she just wasn't sure if she
wanted to see him again no worries so I
text her like hey not a problem
um I get it if you change your mind let
me know you have my number but if not
good luck out there and I figured I'd be
the end of it
um and then like a week or two later no
contact she hits me up and I get a
second date awesome
um so we go out and I figured I'd do
better this time but it was painfully
obvious that I wasn't gonna get a third
date out of this
um so towards the end I just decided to
ask her like what like why did I get the
second date if you knew this wasn't for
you and Trisha told me that it was
because of the way I handled the
rejection after the first date like I
didn't freak out I didn't call her like
a [ __ ] or anything like simply because
I was able to take a no for an answer
like we have to do better guys
tell me about the time when you realize
that the bar is super low for men I was
at the club with my friends and we were
dancing having fun and this guy came up
to me and he said oh I'm looking I was
looking at you and I thought you were so
pretty and I just wanted to come over
here and say that and like do you want
to like kiss a little bit and I said no
I I don't because I'm here with my
friends and I'm just having fun I'm not
interested and he said oh that's all
right then sorry for bothering you and
he turned around and walked away
I have never found someone more
attractive in my entire life and I said
to my friend I almost want to go after
him and kiss him because he was
respectful
when I tell you the bar is way down in
hell
I'm not kidding
not kidding
tell me about the time when you realize
that the bar is super low for men I'm
gonna tell y'all how easy it is to get a
female to like you in college if a girl
is interested in you enough to come to
your room and chill with you this is all
you got to do when she comes to your
room invite her to sit on the bed
you pull out a chair and sit in that
[ __ ] do not go near her do not
touch her just talk with her chill and
Vibe the entire time do this the first
and maybe the second time y'all hang out
and she'll be so shocked and impressed
that you weren't just trying to [ __ ]
that she gonna attack you next time
y'all hang out mark my words tell me
about the time when you realize that the
bar is super
okay so
um the reason I brought this up is
because whenever oftentimes when I have
a lot of girls on my show
um I always hear stories like this where
they just tell me like the absolute
worst stop story that's ever happened to
them in their life
um
and it just doesn't seem indicative of
what I've experienced with men so why do
you think every girl has a sob story
when it comes to men
I'm happy to start
um why do girls have a soft story
because
um
because emotions are actually what's
valuable
because that's that's why we're alive
because when we are living we feel and
when we feel it it actually has some
type of meaning so let's for example say
something very mundane do you remember
what you ate this breakfast for
breakfast this morning
maybe not because it was just a regular
day do you remember let's say like it
was your graduation day
do you remember what you had for
breakfast maybe you didn't even eat
because you're so you were so you were
so nervous you're going on stage you're
going to get your you know so so
emotions is what makes things stick
you're not going to remember something
if it wasn't something exciting we don't
have the brain capacity to remember
everything so our brains are made to
process and really hone in on things
that they think is important so whether
that is Extreme happiness extreme Bliss
extreme ecstasy to The Other Extreme of
hurt and rejection pain trauma those are
the things that we are going to always
remember so it doesn't matter if maybe
this girl actually had
100 really good encounters with guys but
she doesn't value them because maybe
she's numb to it and then all it takes
is that one time because maybe she's so
traumatized at one point of her life and
so when she does come across someone who
validates her her
um her perception which is that men are
bad then she just latches on and then
she gets very angry why don't men do the
same thing they do the same it's not a
gender it's not a gender thing because
men and women
one of them are different in the sense
that women are a lot more volatile and
they're a lot more outside when it comes
to expressing their emotions the problem
with men is that you do feel and I
actually think that men feel more but
the problem without feeling more I'm
talking about men like women demonizing
men versus men demonizing women I'm just
curious do you guys feel like men and
women do it the same just going around
yes or no no no definitely not what
about no no what about you Ash
but
sorry
um what was the question do you think
men and women demonize each other the
same no no can I actually say what I
actually think maybe why women I don't
know about the men but I think this is
why women are so
well why the feminists are so angry okay
um so
I'm gonna say Feminine energy because I
believe that we all have a little bit of
both and that's that's actually a good
thing to have we have both in us and
depending on the right situation you
will lean into one more than the other I
think you see it more in a girl because
I I guess we're more encouraged to be
more masculine these days anyways now I
think when girls innately are female
feminine energy they do want to feel
cherished they want to be taken cared of
that is like the most pure basic feeling
to start with right now what
unfortunately happens is that
when girls start maturing so when they
start getting into teenage years when
they start getting awareness of you know
sexuality in themselves they also
unfortunately girls tend to mature
quicker than guys so they outperform
them sometimes at school they're more
quicker at focusing and honing into
growing up and being a little bit more
adulty whereas guys might take a little
bit longer and it just it is just what
it is guys just takes a little bit
longer and that's okay I think I agree
just because I think I agree with
majority of what you're saying but I
think the point that seems to get uh
missed out these days is that
your you have more feminine energy
that's because you're born that way we
have more masculine energy because we're
going away I think the society now the
problem is to say we're trying to make
each other so similar even though we're
much similar than we're different we
need to appreciate the differences
between us so I don't think there's any
benefits to a man being feminine even
though this is what females are
requesting nowadays I want my guy to be
more in touch with the feminine so
there's actually no benefit to it
because as a man
you cry we I mean men cry it's not it's
not it's not like we don't cry but
he'd cry in front of your girl and see
what happens she's not going to respect
you know I've heard policy doesn't all
pretends because it's true
women are actually requesting these days
like it's actually it's not going to
benefit them in a relationship you don't
want a weak man as soon as you as soon
as you see that your man is weak you're
gonna go or sweat so yeah I mean I agree
and and I I will I that's a very valid
point I agree with you as well and I get
where you're coming from I think just to
finish off my point so
what from what I said earlier girls then
get pushed if you can see what I'm
saying get pushed to become very
masculine because they feel like and
actually it's from personal experience
my own mother tells me to my they're
pushing us to go to college they're
pushing us to go into very masculine you
know type of Trades and in order to be
I'm in the medical field so in order to
be look if you're coming to see me do
you want me to be a woman who doesn't
know how to make decisions yeah no you
don't want that right real quick because
it's a very important distinction you
just made then I don't hear much women
say it's like you just said that your
mother encourages you to be more
masculine What I Hear nowadays is we as
we know on the Internet is men versus
women like we don't hear much of
examples of your mother encouraging we
hear men make us like these men make us
you've just been honest there and said
and do you think I'm going to say it's
driving that's a problem
that um women are making women become
more masculine yeah that's an issue um
but it's just just before I discovered
um
that's an important distinction it's not
the men that's doing that because we
want you to be feminine like men want
women to be feminine we don't want you
to be masculine we already got to deal
with the dudes that I'm asking we don't
want to deal with a masculine female so
it's an issue I think I'm definitely
going to agree with you with that and
I'm going to get to the point you made
as well so what happens is that then the
girls are encouraged to stand up for
themselves don't wait around and rely on
the guy you've got to be self-sufficient
by the way that's a good thing because
you actually if if you're going into a
relationship you want a partnership you
would want so this is how it works so
have you ever seen 300 uh-huh have you
why would you why would you want a
partnership when that's not how it's
worked for all of history what I meant
by partnership I'll explain a little bit
okay
in 300 Leonidas is the king and he has
his Queen
when
when someone comes to his doorstep and
threatens him literally threatens his
his whole livelihood his people
with literally cutting people's heads
off walking up to him and showing
violence
his Queen stepped up and said
this is not okay
and the messenger was turning around and
saying how dare you as a woman speak
and in the end when Leonidas then before
he kicked them down the well
he actually said you disrespected my
queen and actually what she said as well
is she said like only Spartan women can
give birth to Spartan men which is
strong men so what is beautiful about
that relationship is that they are not
equal in the sense that they don't have
the same energy but
we can agree that they're both strong in
different ways that's not a partnership
because he needs okay so what I meant is
I'm not saying you're eating she needs
him more than he needs her so what I'm
saying is I'm not saying that they're
equal and that they give the same thing
in but what they do is that they
complement each other and support each
other and the beautiful thing about that
relationship is that she's actually very
accomplished so he feels safe walking
away and going into war potentially
never coming back but he knows that his
wife is strong so she can go and she
will use her way of doing things to try
and help the country can I just say
something so is it is a definition of a
partnership 50 50 right you're right so
I think that's the biggest problem for
men when we hear partnership because we
think
when we hear 50 50 we think hold on so
if we gotta if we gotta get into a fight
now it's not 50 50 because if someone
comes to robust down the street right
now it's not 50 50. I gotta deal with
100 of the I gotta deal with him so when
we hear partnership we think that's cool
because there's certain places where we
want women to be feminine so if we're a
family government
you might be more vocal than us that's
fine because we don't want to talk so
there's it's like a partnership doesn't
have to be 50 50 in my opinion we can
you can have a solid relationship
without having to be 50 50 all the way
we can you can be bearish women can be
better some things and men as I you're
more maternal than us you can do with
children better than us we're fine with
that the problem with women nowadays in
my opinion we're trying to make
everything so equal and it's like it's
just not like that it's not enough it's
not it's not in our biological it's not
innate at all yeah and I agree with you
with that as well because I I I guess I
have the my definition of Partnerships a
bit different from you so when I'm
seeing a partnership I didn't mean it
has to be 100 50 50 in every single
aspect right but you're changing the
definition of a word okay
so I do apologize I'm not trying no I'm
not offended I'm just I'm just saying
like that's not what it means um
question for you what have you seen in
divorce court do you feel like men and
women demonize each other the same
what's your experience with that uh
no I think women are more ready to just
demonize their husband like if they're
going in the arena of divorce like okay
this is happening they're ready to just
cut him out as much you know whatever
way possible
and I've seen very confident lovers like
okay what's going on who is this you
know where does this come from and then
he just has to it's sad so first initial
reaction is he's sad he's like okay this
is this is where it's going and then he
has to just now defend himself all his
accusations so yeah and then he might be
disgusted and then he's just retaliating
but she's the one that always starts it
glad you said that I've seen just saying
how it is so I'm curious um have you had
I know the majority of divorces are
initiated by women have you had men
initiate divorce yeah sometimes what are
the typical reasons that men initiate
from what you've seen so what I've seen
so sometimes it's adultery okay or she
gets to like she's trying to take charge
in the house and started demanding
things so she's she doesn't have to like
if she's if especially if she's educated
so she's got got a job
and she's coming home late and then she
can't she's too tired what's the
percentage is just roughly off your
experience of men initiating divorcement
initiated divorce the percentage well I
don't know because I know I know the
percentage that Paul's got statistics
but what have you seen in your own
experience men initiate yeah like
roughly the last time we saw is around
like 15
really and yeah that means it's a cystic
spot on me that's how bad it is yeah but
again the English quotes I have to say
we it's not like straight away it's not
as bad as California I'm going to say
for for example how how long do you
think women want to leave marriages
before they do
about how long yeah typically so from as
soon as they get married and yeah like
like um they just always say like if a
girl starts working out and going to the
gym she's leaving your ass
I mean that's really relative I don't
know maybe I would say it's like six
months six months to a few years it
sounds really extreme but if it keeps
happening there's all these pattern
suits yeah okay
um so what about you guys you guys have
ex-girlfriends no I never never had an
ex really yeah no I got a girl no I've
never had it how long do you know that
well we was together 10 years and we
split off for three years and then we
got back together okay yeah right oh
that's pretty cute yeah
um does she demonize you oh yeah 100 she
does yeah
um
I'm not going to get into the details
because I'm not here to be emotional or
anything like that but it was um it was
quite a let's just say abusive simply
um and she loved to demonize me for it
and you know I had the the mindset back
then I still do you know like if she's
dressing as we'd say like a slug then I
wouldn't have it and then what Anna said
to her like if you want to dress like
that that's fine but don't like don't be
with me you know you still got your
choice I'm not controlling choice but
she'd take that admit me into being
controlling but
like I don't know she turned me into the
the demon and then um
I think what she was doing is girth
lighting so which sadly happens both
ways because I personally have only have
one X and he did exactly that to me for
a good two years and it's it's it it's
it's been literally a life-changing
experience and I think what's really sad
is that this is literally like it
doesn't matter what gender there are
good people out there who just you know
we were simple-minded people who just
wanted to we were excited to meet
someone who we thought we were going to
be happy with and these people are
they're so good at manipulating you they
love bomb you they say you oh my God I
love you I want to have your kids what
like you just fall for them and when
they have their clothes in you boom
right they start coming in and you're
like I think girls like toxic man I
agree I agree yeah yeah I think like
there's something you're attracted to
about it do you know why
um well I think it's because like the
same traits the hero has the villain has
too so if a dude is very like they
always say like why why does that girl
stay with her girlfriend or that why
does the girl stay with the boyfriend
that beats her up well it's because like
that aggression that's in the hero is
also in the villain you ask any girl if
when they say like they got a crush a
celebrity crush or something I guarantee
he's gonna be the villain in the movie
they let the bad guys it's just
would it be okay if I just just make the
distinction and the reason why these
girls are getting it wrong
yes they women actually go look in a
romance novel men like their corn girls
like the books we look very differently
and you can go to Romans now one in a
bookstore you can see that girls tend to
go for the hunky guys the the vampires
the bad boys and they changed them right
it's all about changing them now now now
the important thing is is that they are
actually innately attracted that's what
I'm saying girls start off the feminine
energy does want the man though they
want the masculine
um but because they're jaded and then
they they had to what do you mean
because they're Jade they want the
masculine because because I genuinely
feel that they
obviously it's from personal experience
I as a as a young girl that's why I was
remembered like I I have a very
traditional family my mother has stayed
at home took care of the kids my father
was the breadwinner for me that is
normal that is what I saw myself
envisioned myself with and
sadly because times have changed
um my my mom started saying you can't
just you know rely on a guy you've got
to also have your craft you you've got
to have something to bring to the table
so I agreed I said yeah of course so I
went out there I spent the time on
myself and I really like worked on
myself try to be a good you know like a
good Society person in society
but the thing is then in that journey I
became too masculine right I overshot
and then I'm starting to give bro Vibes
and and then of course then these girls
are asking why am I not getting the guy
the masculine guy well one
um you're too masculine I know that
because I was there once I had to teach
myself I had to remind myself that I
need to tone it down there are certain
times where that's appropriate such as
when I'm in a more work situation and I
have to be more decisive but when I'm on
a date well I am different I I want I
want a masculine man I defined I
actually looked at myself and I said
what do I want do I want if I'm in a man
or do I want a masculine why did why did
your mom why do you think your mom um
encouraged you to be masculine if it
seemed to have worked out well for her
she got to provide her husband and like
very sad actually we had this
conversation and my mom said to me she
said in my times she said guys just came
up to me all the time now I will say
this my mom's very feminine she's like
the Damsel in Distress so she does
attract guys anyways but she was saying
like I would used to walk on the street
and I will see great quality men
everywhere like I feel like I can just
pick them off the street they're all
great but I don't know she said I don't
know what's going on she was like it
makes me really sad but I feel like
guys are not as High Caliber anymore and
I'm worried for my daughter I'm scared
that they're going to not be able to
deal with themselves
and they don't have that support the
person either so so to compensate she's
pushing me on the other direction of
being self-sufficient but the danger of
that is that it's over it was overshot I
think that's a common problem now so
yeah like you said your mom's pushing
that way just to go back on your point
that you mean before the fact that you
realized you was too masculine that is
that is what
men I think today are asking women to do
it just for me I've got female friends
that I've got boyfriends and they
sometimes they ask me for advice and I
just tell them look in the mirror and I
don't and I say look in the mirror and
I'm not talking about look at your body
your face I'm saying look in the mirror
and look at the person you're being when
you're going to restaurants like how are
you trying to you trying to dominate the
situation when you go to family
gathering trying to dominate like you
have to let your man be a man and
exactly women find the problem yeah do
you guys think there's a shortage of
husbands or wives
that's an interesting question
um
I'd say there's a shortage on husbands
because men like it's just not worth it
like any logical man which most men it's
safe to say illogical I'd say it just
doesn't make sense
oh because they don't want to get
married that's what you're saying okay
what do you think shortage of husbands
or wives it depends on where as I said
in the west so so this is England U.S
[Music]
um I can I'd like you to so you think
you sort of explained a little bit you
think it's because men don't want to get
married yeah um I I don't think it's
that men don't want to get married like
I'd love to get married but to the right
woman that I know that wouldn't like
just Chuck my [ __ ] you know what I mean
because I have very big plans for my
future and I'm not trying to risk it for
knowing because like if a woman can
marry me for a year and take everything
that I've worked for over all these
years and put every ounce of effort into
then like
as someone who wants to get into
business that does not seem like good
business you know like that sounds like
a bad move so me that's that's more of a
point to why I think there's less wives
so I think traditionally and even
currently men caught women we go out and
we try to find a woman so if we can't
find a woman I think that's the problem
now it's like we're not we're not making
it blunt enough like
men don't want to get married to the
current women and we have multiple
reasons for that like let's not talk
about only fans let's not talk about
masculine women like it's it's simple
like we just don't think women are good
enough now for us to settle down and
marry so do you think that women don't
think they're good enough for men or men
don't think they're good or do you think
it's um because I think that like women
don't think men are good enough for them
even if they're average
yeah that's the problem isn't it yeah
yeah I think because if you look in
history I don't
I think women dated and married average
guys historically because a lot a
question I ask on my show often is like
how much does your submission cost
and um and I say like to the point that
like he said quit your job tomorrow be
with the kids you do it yeah I've seen
you Austin for the Saturday and they
always say six figures even if they're
fives even though that's the percent how
much people how much men in the world
don't see yeah and I so then the next
question is always are you a top ten
percent girl and they say no and so it's
like you have girls that are not top 10
asking for a top 10 outcomes in order to
submit I think the word submit bothers
women just the word submit buffers them
construed to be honest I think they uh
I've heard this before someone I'm not
sure where but uh I heard that women
tend to think submission means slavery
like they think what the months is is
just absolutely final without reason you
know what I mean when submission really
is just um you know it's not that you
don't get to say in the matter it's just
that there's a leader and you're second
in command there's someone in primary
command but you're still in second in
command
and you have a lot of influence too it's
like like because you can
I mean ever every person knows like that
couple that's like really cute we're
like even even though the guy's in
charge like the woman's kind of in
charge because she's just so feminine
and kind of can can get him to like see
her point of view you know you get
there's a couple that comes to your head
right is that okay I'm gonna give you an
example it's a little bit extreme but
you actually see the very clear actually
this will it's controversial if you
think about it but it's the healthiest
relationships are from the BDSM
community and I will I will explain why
because I need to find healthy no no so
I need you to like if someone claim this
the reason why I say it's healthy is in
order to be able to be in that type of
relationship because it is so extreme to
the point where sometimes there is a
chance of death yeah because people
engage in such extreme activities you
need extreme trust in order to get into
it is there is there any data that backs
this up so the the idea no this just
sounds like this sounds crazy so I I
know I'm I'm going to give you the
example okay because things are so
extreme you're not just going to do it
even though it's a fantasy you're not
going to do it unless you trust that
person it's not going to actually kill
you does that make sense so you have to
discuss all the details you you say what
do I like what I don't like they talk
about what are the things that you might
consider what are the things what is a
hard no what is a soft no what is and
after you've done all of that and you
agree that you're going to give it a try
you have to have a safe word
so what happens in that relationship one
person's the Dom one person's a sub
who holds the power
the Dumber is that just sexually though
no no no that's that's yes that's that's
that's a trick question the ultimate
power is the sub why because they can
determine when it stops exactly and
that's the beauty of submission ladies
it's the beauty of
submitting because you know that you
trust that person so much that you
literally trust them with your life
and it's beautiful because you say to
this man I am willing to submit to you I
trust you ultimately for my livelihood
and my well-being ultimately I trust you
100 and I know that if because it is
negotiable if I am uncomfortable even
slightly and I don't I want to get out
of it I want to step away you have my
back you will respect me and you are
going to give me that ability to walk
away and just just to add to that
um
think when women hear submission they
just think like
demands in front and they're just behind
like I'm telling you women that does not
that's not what submission means like
and there's certain points like I said
before that men actually like you to be
uh in the Forefront so like I said
before in a fam you go to a family
gathering right we don't want to be
putting up plates for the kids and
making sure everyone's fed like that's
that's when you can dominate the
situation it doesn't mean we have to be
headhunt all the time it just means the
majority of the time
weigh yourself we're there for you to
protect you we're there to provide for
you so it hasn't got to be all the way
like where you're just running along a
way like in front of you there's gonna
be certain points where they dominate so
um I'm curious for you why do you think
there's a shortage of
um wives
I don't I think they're uh jeopardizing
their chances to be wise but I think
there's a lot of potential husbands but
you could also make the argument there's
a shortage of both because they're being
turned off because
does that make sense because of the law
yeah yeah and so yeah but I think the
more women are jeopardizing their
potential to be wives but I think
there's loads of potential husbands who
can actually get into the husband role
like they could be but it's just they
don't have the right girl to become that
exactly what what mistakes do you see
girls make that takes them out of the
running to be wives
um I don't know I just wanna
if I could just
simply say it well if they're if they
could easily get sucked into things like
feminism like you know overall yeah I
know people say oh but there's this type
of feminism
you know I think we could all agree that
all this like men are trash and all that
stuff that's probably the biggest
mistake if you can if you can allow that
in you know in your mindset and think
that that's okay that's probably the
biggest one
that turns men off because you can even
just say that's that that's enough
because in feminism they say you don't
have to do this he could just accept you
the way you are you don't have to do
anything you just have to exist and
going back to the actual topic of what
we're talking about the bar is set very
just ridiculously high for men to the
point where I I I think that they
deliberately do that to take the piss
it's just so high it's unattainable but
for women I feel like there is no but it
doesn't even exist so you can see that
there you see the girls on my 300 pound
life with a man I
is that monthly no I haven't even seen
that
yeah I personally I personally think
that the problem these days in modern
culture whatever you want to call it is
that people is actually focusing on the
wrong things so these girls are talking
about and I think there was recently
these guys who came in and said they
were high value men and they wear flashy
stuff they act you know a certain way
and I can tell you that a high value
woman the ones that you actually the
good ones that you want as a wife
they're not going to say yes to it that
guy because they're gonna see him and be
like oh he's so insecure he needs to
drive a Lambo in order to feel slightly
slightly better about himself slightly
because guess what under all those
cologne nice shirts whatever Gucci belts
whatever you want to call it
it's a very insecure person who needs
that physical
reassurement because guess what the the
real men the real value men they don't
wear anything flashy you don't even know
they have money that's the beauty they
wear same t-shirt every day and they're
the true men with the values they're the
ones who they're dangerous they they
know their stuff and if they want to
inflict danger they know but the beauty
about them is that they have that that
that everything's under control so if
anyone wants to mess with them you know
you're gonna get burned but because
they're so in control and in their King
energy they they they the girls know
that he is a good person to be with
because he can protect me but he also
will respect me and love me so I think
yeah sorry bro um so quick question um
this is just from the chat
um have you had a BDSM relationship
personally mean no but it's something
that you saw 50 Shades of Gray and
you're like sign me up no no
uh can I just put it out there the 50
Shades of Gray is the worst depiction of
BDSM there is okay ever it is it is a
completely wrong and that is an abusive
relationship that is not BDSM that is
not from every relationship Every Woman
fans what's the guy's name because I
know there was a reading the book on the
show oh Mr Gray yeah well it's the same
thing girls like the handmaid's tale
this is the thing like so girls are
attracted to their that's the thing
they're confused what they want is the
healthy relationship the king who is you
can tell he can inflict you know trauma
and real real real real real things like
he can protect his family he can protect
his people but he controls it he's in
control of himself these girls are
fooled because they don't we sometimes
when you're young and you don't know
better you're followed by these girls
you know girls intuition but we're not
fooled they don't use that language
because it's not correct women women's
intuition is so freaking I'm not saying
we're not we no no we are not like that
when we say words like fooled it's
implying that we don't know what we're
doing and that it's a cop-out for women
it's like oh we're fooled by the flashy
stuff come on okay I'm not trying to say
that I'm not trying to say that
everyone's like that but from personal
experience I I was I I was I am a person
who fell for someone who I thought was a
king he tried she didn't see a single
red flag because I would I didn't know
how to see it you didn't okay this is a
thing I'm just being like I'm just being
real with you it just sounds like
excuses no no no I I of course I believe
you yeah and actually for the longest
time I noticed that I attracted the same
type of guys men that unfortunately
didn't think about me it was all about
them it wasn't about me and and you know
what I realized that what was the
constant here me yeah yeah that's the
one thing that hasn't changed so why am
I getting the same experiences so rather
than try to say that it's their fault
I looked at myself and I said what am I
not what am I missing right how am I
going to take you to get there though
like what age did you start looking at
yourself because that's what I encourage
all my female friends to just look at
himself and see the problems within them
so before they start putting a finger
yeah look you should start start
whenever I mean the thing is is that
like I was always a bit late in dating
scene anyways like my first and only
boyfriend was when I was 22. I was with
him for two years I honestly thought
this was someone I was going to marry
that's how serious I was but guess what
he was a narcissist he gaslighted me all
the time his whole family was was he was
he diagnosed
um he's very self-centered and
everything was about but he was never
diagnosed because okay because like
again this in a way is an excuse like
with that women use because if he hasn't
seen a therapist and he hasn't been
professionally diagnosed you can't
diagnose him as a narcissist I think
it's difficult because I know it's not
it's not difficult you know it's like if
he if he's not hasn't been diagnosed as
a narcissist we can't just go around
calling people narcissists so I'm gonna
say narcissistic traits what that means
is that a person is coming across a
certain way where they're not diagnosed
I apologize if anyone pay offense to
that I think I want to answer Paul's
question
um with regards to what are the mistakes
women make
um in becoming web so I think personally
today's women think that
identifying with feminism is a good
long-term strategy
and it's clearly not because
as you said men appreciate youth men
appreciate fertility so I think the
biggest problem with feminism for me is
that
feminism encourages Independence right
and in today's society for females
Independence means in my opinion
incredibly promiscuous so they end up
sleeping with multiple guys figuring to
do the same thing as men because
normally it depends me you can do what
you want right by yourself
but it's clearly not working out for
anyone I mean suppose all the statistics
about
I mean what age are women getting
married now what age are women having
kids now like it's not working out for
women at all so go ahead can I mention
that that video I mean
is that a big deal like what they were
mentioning you're exaggerating it's like
the light thing like come on
what if it was like let me just try to
guess it's gonna concentrated stuff yeah
that's the issue
yeah like the point is that girls make
every sob story out of everything I
don't understand why that's a sub I'm
sorry I might be a bit slow but I
genuinely don't understand but you see
the men you see the men enabling them
too yeah because the manner the men are
saying oh like all you have to do is be
nice to a girl but it's funny because
the girl the second guy the girl was
just using like she was using for
attention he walked away after the date
then she wanted the attention got a site
like got another date out of him and
then it was like see this is where we
have to speak about remember this is
where we have to speak about men a bit
because I think men
I think there's a lot of delusional men
too as much as um it's probably the only
bit I'll stick up for me so I might as
well get out of the way now
um I've seen men in just just going out
nightclubs and such I've seen men get
upset when they can't get the baddest
girl in the club and I'm looking at them
thinking like what do you what are you
what what's what are you like your
average looking dude for starters do you
have swag do you have money and you're
upset that you can't get the baddest
girl in a club like
it's like yeah there's a lot of
delusional men too I can't just throw it
all on women I've seen many things in my
life I'm just looking at dude like
you're not gonna get that shorty I got a
question for you son sure you mentioned
earlier you like to bring up to um to
women you know just look in the mirror
right or I'm not sure about down south
but where I'm from up North most of the
women and I'm sure anyone from the north
would agree with me I ratchet right
right and um if you even start to bring
up accountability they will fly off the
handle and it will not end well for you
know like even if you put your foot down
they'll throw a pun at your head you
know what I mean so they're crazy so
what what would be your advice for that
yeah they're crazy I can give you the
quick strategy but I I know how to oh go
ahead go ahead I can give you that I
can't give any guy that's watching how
to get a girl in a nightclub Academy if
you want to know that like okay this is
the most simplest method that's worked
for me when I was single by the way so
I got more examples I do me and my
friends do this [ __ ] all the time right
so you see a girl that you're attracted
to at the bar right
I woke up there's a there's a long queue
I use my structure I use my stance I use
myself I'm not gonna walk right to the
front and be like you got what are you
guys drinking I'll tell you when I drink
I said cool no worries don't say another
word right
go to the bar order my drink order them
a drink
give it to them and walk off
and I I promise you yeah the amount of
times them same girls think what the
fighting awesome for my number they
didn't ask for my Snapchat what the hell
I literally go cool walk off here they
find you that same night because you're
you're you you're making them think
you're adding you're adding some sort of
like doubt in the world why why not
speaking why ain't ask for my number
like just walk off and then obviously
there's got to be something about you
though I don't want to tell like some
any dude you can just do this and it's
going to be successful like you have to
have something about you like me and my
friends we're very [ __ ] we go out all
over the UK we're simple we get a table
VIP that's it because as we know
American culture UK culture they
appreciate women appreciate that but it
depends what your goal they're trying to
find a wifey that's one thing you're
trying to have fun that night that's
another thing but
I think when men give it all out on the
table there and then women are not
interested because they know that what
they can get from there and it's like
even even the one guy in the reaction
video he said like just don't touch her
yeah
the last two videos in that uh that
video The Tick Tock videos was guys
basically ignoring them and the ladies
were like I've never been more attracted
in my life yeah so uh it's just you
always want what you can't have that's
why what what are the most ridiculous
standards that you've heard men and
women say
men and women yeah so so give me like it
doesn't have to be that high maybe you
haven't heard one that's that high for
one or the other but for a man to like
wife a girl and for a girl to White to
marry a guy what are like the highest
standards you've heard a girl and a guy
say
um well uh one of them has got to be a
single mother talking to me and saying
like oh I want this I want this I want
this up a guy like specifically
um you know just having money having a
car uh having his own house and you know
accommodate yeah how old was she she was
like my age 19. she want to do with the
house yeah yeah so um and maybe she
wasn't on about right now but regardless
no matter the age it's it's very rarely
gonna happen unless if you're gonna find
a simp okay right and we all know how
that's gonna end now what about the most
picky guy you know uh the most picky guy
um
I don't really think I know that many
people
okay okay fair enough go ahead I'll
start off with the guys I know some guys
that are very picky and they don't have
the qualities to be that picky so I've
heard guys like 30 plus talking about my
girl can't have more than three buddies
my girl can have more than four buddies
and I'm like
I mean first of all what are you
offering you still live at your mom's
crib like have you got your own paper
like your own crib no so how are you
asking a girl you're trying to find the
girls when you got free bodies what does
that mean how many people have had sex
with you uh for women I mean I've seen
some bang average looking women talk
about I want a guy that's got six
figures I want a guy that's got his own
Crypt and they're like if my guy's still
living at his mom's house at 22 20 I
don't want and I'm looking I'm thinking
right okay what do you have to offer
I think I'm very blessed that I surround
myself with wonderful people and I'll be
very honest from a personal level I have
I see many beautiful examples of
relationships that work really really
well men and women so for me I it would
just be quoting things on the internet
to be honest so you've never heard
anyone in real life have a super am I
because I have high standards of people
that I surround myself with so that's
why so no answer okay right pretty much
the usual like six figure and all that
stuff but the craziest one I had was the
the 200k engagement ring oh from not
just oh I forgot about it oh yeah oh my
Lord she literally wants a house on her
finger I can't imagine that's just the
engagement ring that's not even the
wedding no I'm cheap you see so I just
couldn't imagine even if I had the money
I would never spend tutor can an
engagement ring and I was actually
thinking about that today this morning
like girl is advertising so she wants a
man who can afford that but then doesn't
she respect him like she doesn't connect
could tour Europe and see all of Europe
India like you could go all around the
world for 200k you're gonna spend that
on a rain yeah in a small a smart guy
who was mid that money by himself is not
going to spend that money at all on a
ring that is the that is the worst
investment as a businessman you could
make it's just not worth it so she
gained his Respect by building this
wealth and then she loses it like he
loses the respect by making such a bad
word oh what if she lost the ring
oh my God
oh my God I don't even like wearing
expensive jewelry can we talk about in
London I genuinely had to tell one of my
friends from Hong Kong who has a big-ish
ring for UK standards which is not big
for us but big for UK and I actually
told her to please can you swing your
ring around because you are going to get
your finger chopped off yeah you don't
know it's it's like why are you she was
traveling why are you wearing this wear
it at home but I was eyebrow firstly
think that people are like they just
think they they're doing it for their
ego so they want to look flashy they
want to look amazing right usually these
people are broke by the way because they
spend it they spend it all on stuff that
they then wear rather than put it in
their wealth and then they and then they
they cry when they get mugs they get
robbed like
well you're the one who's literally
advertising yourself to unfortunately in
a certain way and
girls don't like hearing that you if you
dress a certain way you're gonna attract
a certain type of attention the same
breath say uh I can protect myself and I
don't need a man that's the problem
because if you get if you're a female
you get robbed you're the first person
you're gonna cool it's a man that is one
of the most ridiculous statements I've
ever heard I don't need no man because
like whether you have men personally in
your life or not you're gonna depend on
a man at some point if your boiler
breaks down if uh even if your tires go
for what maybe not tires flat maybe they
can do that but um you know just like
proper grafting stuff so hard labor
stuff they're gonna depend on a man
right so like it's kind of just a lie is
that a red flag to you guys when you're
talking to girls if they say like I'm
strong and independent and that sort of
thing a hundred percent I don't even
want to be associated with that kind of
delusion yeah like that no yeah yeah now
you can say that because the
infrastructure everything's but like you
can just reap now and then I'll just
Expendable Commodities they could just
isn't it isn't it crazy how men built
the world for us and then we [ __ ] on
them as a thank you that's what I'm
saying it is crazy I think I I find it
incredibly incredibly sad incredibly sad
because we're supposed to be coming
together as as as people who who should
love each other and and spread Joy
rather than literally it's hate hate and
anger all the time and I see all these
people and I'm just like
why do you like all this drama by the
way why do you want to come home your
man's tired and then you're gonna I
don't know yell at them because oh I'm
tired and he put his foot up on the
table you know something really silly
and why can't you just have an adult
conversation and respect the fact that
hey he's tired too and yes okay we maybe
there are things that need ironing out
but why don't we have an adult
conversation why do you have to raise
your voice and be disrespectful to each
other
um did you see did you guys see that
video it was a tick tock video and it
went pretty viral of this uh military
wife and
um she were bitching her husband trying
to uh get him to do the laundry and this
is while he was like off for like I
don't know I don't know how it works in
the US but it's like the rougher two the
two weeks on for a certain period of
time but it was off and
um she were like complaining about him
doing the laundry well you know when
he's on duty he's risking his life even
in training you know because training
deaths happen a lot so like it's just
mad to me that that's even like
[Music]
that guy deserves so much better yeah
can I just point out what the problem is
it's not even the fact that she did it
it's the fact that it's even public
um men deserve responses
I'm not saying that that's not even the
worst bit is what I'm saying the fact
that she made it public yeah she's
literally publicly humiliating this poor
man I'm sorry if you have a problem be
an adult talk to each other as adults
you trying to air your dirty laundry
literally to other people so if you
girls do this all the time I see it and
it's I hate it they they will they will
go to their friends and hang out
together and then all of a sudden
they're gonna say oh my God what's the
problem with the man they like can't
they just like put like their trousers
like can I just put it in the basket I
even got a really nice basket it's like
there I put it in the spot where he
drops it and and he just went do it I
don't get it like what's wrong with him
and I'm just like why are you doing this
to him
um so question let's go around what are
your personal standards yeah so what
would you expect from a woman and what
would you guys expect oh man like
minimum requirements to date them well
I'd say right now I can't expect much
um but I am you know in the process as I
said I'm young and uh I do plan on you
know making six figures eventually I got
the six foot down unlock and I think I'm
pretty cute So eventually I'll have the
standards set in place but right now I'm
focus on on my career but I do have you
know anticipations for my standards
which is um you know submission like
um and
just
Peace of Mind someone who can offer me
peace of mind you know someone that's
not always in my head like you did this
wrong I don't want that you know like if
I'm if I'm willing to provide right um
and be the breadwinner then
um if she wants to work fine but
obviously the the common thing is that
you prefer she stays home yes but yeah
if she does want to work right everyone
says you need a you need the masculine
trait to work right
um especially in a career so
but like when she gets home
she drops that masculinity at the door
because I'm not I'm not competing in my
own household I gotta compete with other
men out in the world to look at me six
foot tattoos beard and then they just
like assume I'm top dog and then
competition time I don't know if that's
more of a you thing so like because I'm
a you but uh yeah it's certainly what
I'm experiencing right now so I
definitely do not want to have that in
the household that I'm paying for
yeah I agree I think for me my woman
must offer peace man because I know how
much I work I know how when I come home
I want her that my household to be my my
safe space to be you know peaceful and
relaxed and also
I think the most number one thing is
she's gotta be she's gotta be feminine
she has to be able to submit
um she has to be family orientated
because I don't have kids yet but that's
that's the main goal I want to have kids
I want her to be a family based person
um preaching yeah is that how your girl
is now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
we're working on it so don't put me
under pressure
good so um I do want
in my terms I do want a a man who
respects me I want a masculine man so
exactly what you guys are saying a man
who has great achievements he has a path
he's ready to work on himself to make
himself better and he also respects me
and someone that I will feel proud of
and I would want to give him the love
and support as you said as a woman and
be his his number one fan I want to be
his home I want to be the person that he
can come to me where everyone else he'll
be a bit on guard and he will feel
comfortable to just drop it a little bit
because I am his home so what what does
he have to have because you're kind of
describing what you want to be for him
but the question was like what what does
he have to be in order to get that so
for me it's rather than the if you have
a height requirement no no he could be
short at five foot I dated a man that
was shorter than me before for two years
okay so I'm I'm not I will say this I'm
not very normal but
for me I have learned the value of the
true value of a person isn't their
exterior it's it's their insides it's
their personalities it's whether they
fit me so for example one of the things
because I did a personality test of
Jordan Peterson's okay and one of the
things he looks at is agreeableness and
one of my criteria I want for my man is
I want him to be less agreeable than me
why because I am quite agreeable and I'm
always worrying that maybe I might step
on someone's toes but someone who's less
agreeable is not going to be as easily
uh you know like offended so I like that
I don't have to feel you know like can I
tell you are you gonna get offended so
for example so okay this is like kind of
broad so I just I want to be a little
bit more specific so you want someone
disagreeable what else
so what's some more disagreeable does he
have to respectful income income
required I would like him to be
um from a skill set knowledge income
level equal to me okay which is roughly
well I um I earn around 3 000 a month so
maybe something like that okay
um is there anything else that you want
roughly like at your income or more
would you ever submit to a guy that
makes less than you
yes because it's not about the now
people are changing no no he's staying
at that it's not build a man so he said
no no it's not I'm not saying that I'm
trying to build him but this is a thing
like just because a man may not be as
good now doesn't mean he isn't later
it's about real life no but I'm saying
like a lot of times like girls we try to
build a man like we go to build a bear
but but guys like like I don't know what
I'm saying I'm saying like when you said
it's not about the now it's about the
later that's implying that you're you
would want him to his income to increase
but I'm saying like most guys kind of
are where they're at especially like you
said you're 34. so if a guy's 35 like 35
like I'd imagine you want roughly your
age or older
so so maybe for me that's the thing like
so for me I
honestly all I'm gonna say is I've
realized that the physical shell of
things
they're not as important as peace and
the the person that's inside does that
come of age though did you realize that
100 right this is and this is the thing
like this is something I've learned this
is something that I internalized I had
to go I was single for I'm been single
still single for a long time because
guess what I needed to work on myself
like if I'm broken and I'm not in the
right frame of mind I'm gonna end up
damaging another person I don't want
that if I'm not ready then I'm gonna
work on myself and to be honest like yes
I'll be it's difficult to give you a
figure but the people with the six
figures who are getting all these girls
and driving Lambos I don't want them
either is is monogamy a requirement for
you for me yes okay do you feel like
that's a fair deal for a guy
um because he's not getting you for your
best years
that depends on what the man wants so
I'm saying like long term like I'm and
this is going for like me too none of us
are virgins anymore
so I think like men value Purity and
youth right and they're not getting that
anymore so do you think it's a fair deal
for men when they're not getting that to
be monogamous to us to comprise on their
mating strategy when we don't fulfill
theirs because we're not virgins anymore
because I feel like when you talk about
something and saying that that's the
only reason you have value I think
that's wrong
it's not I'm not saying that's the only
reason you have value I'm talking about
your value in the dating market and like
like results are harsh the world's harsh
and like the truth is modern women are
less pure than they've ever been and
we're older than we've ever been so I'm
asking do you think that's a fair deal
for men when they have to be more and
more less
if a man is going to look at me and say
that the only value I come I can bring
to the table is because of my no I
didn't say the only value so I'm not
saying that's the only value like you
seem like a smart girl I know you have
more than just that but I'm saying in
the dating market like this is what it
starts with and it's harsh but it's
reality
so yeah just um but you're saying we're
going with age and we're going with well
it's like men men value Purity and youth
so they like young virgins that's the
that's the ideal just like our ideal is
like rich men right but I'm saying now
in today's day and age like women have
higher standards than ever but bring
less to the table than ever we're older
we've slept with more people and we have
less loyalty because we're the ones
leaving them
yeah so I'm saying do you think that's a
fair deal for men
I think it generally depends on the
person I'm sorry I can't answer that
question okay go ahead what are your
requirements for a guy uh that he's
aware of the the traditional gender
roles okay and I expect that and he
expects that from me and reciprocity and
I think respect is earned I can't I
don't expect him just to respect me just
like that because I'm a woman I think he
needs to get to know me and um the
relationship has to be reciprocal and I
I'm 28 and I don't
I actually want him to be polygenous
really yeah
they're gonna fall in love with you in
the church
the reason why and um I could speak so
much about this they're calling you an
Indian Queen right now
why
like I need my solitude and I I hate
saying that because people are like oh
God you know she's so up there but I
really like I get drained so me coming
today I was like I really need to
prepare myself yeah yeah um because I
get joined with interaction and I'm I if
I love my husband
and I need to get over the fact that I
don't need to be clinged on time because
I sound realistic
um but if I love my husband I want him
to be taken care of and and if I don't
have to worry about that yeah that's
great wow and that's as simple as I can
put it how are you how are you single
what's like no no I'm not oh okay she's
sorry guys sorry I forgot I thought you
said you were no but yeah I mean I know
that there is so much that could be said
about that isn't he yeah heart eyes
Indian woman I was like
oh no sorry well I've got a question
um are you in a polygenous relationship
uh I'm with somebody who is open to that
and and hey that's great for me would
you want multiple wives or would you
just want like he could step out
whenever he wants the thing is I I would
that he would they would have to be
wives okay because you know because then
because I would lose respect for him
because then I'm like then you know you
guys are using each other and no yeah so
if we can actually marry them and you
know them if there's children out there
accidentally you know I want my children
to have you know honorable half siblings
not like just some you know Straight
Talk
No I don't care if I'm too I just you
know I'm so over it like you know and
and guess what it's very freeing yeah
it's very freaking is that um are you
from India or like or is that is that
common in India or no is that like
something I don't know I haven't seen it
like well yeah actually yes it is it is
okay but not as common but it does
happen but answer your
another question they have in the chat
is what age do you see women divorce men
typically
what age yeah
say around 40s I've seen a lot of that
really 40s I thought it would be like
30. yeah yeah actually yeah 30s yeah
late 30s 40s
because oh you know what I bet it is you
could still maybe move on in 30s to 40s
but if you're in your 50s like what's no
that's I actually that was somebody
who's the white the ex-wife is 38 and
she's like I can see the window so I'm
gonna take it yeah you know well good
luck to her for this so it's like their
hypergamy would you say yeah yeah okay
I'm gonna take a second to read super
chats that's
that they're like he's the luckiest man
alive we've got a unicorn here yeah no I
don't think I've ever had a girl I don't
think I've heard that have we had a girl
on the show that said she was open to
that
no no no
I've had like 20 people a week but the
last episode in the building and it
happens yeah
for real episode 69 yeah yeah hell yeah
should I start you writing earlier when
he was talking yeah I was taking notes I
had to like who's talking I need to
learn some things you know what I'm
saying yeah I got you okay um guys go
subscribe to our Clips Channel we just
got that to 25 000 Subs so make sure you
go subscribe to also like the video
y'all a like is free you don't have to
deal with the notifications okay if you
that's what some of you guys say I don't
want all the notifications fine fine
like the video then it's free
um on top of that we're going to be
turning um our chat on to members only
the rest of the chats if you want to be
a part of that I know grown grown
everyone's like no but that's what we're
doing this is business so five dollars a
month to be a part of the chat ten
dollars to see our vlogs
um then you can connect with us on
social media and you can get a
one-on-one call with us once a month on
top of that guys follow my Instagram
just dot pearly things and this is our
last show tonight in this apartment but
now I'm gonna Read Super chats I just
want to make sure I go through all of
the announcements so Zach Banks um
Toronto in the house showing love Pearl
is facts say no more
um silly sausage strong and independent
is just being able to pay for yourself
so you're telling me that you're not
homeless okay good for you that is an
achievement to that is not an
achievement to brag about it is
literally the bare minimum expected of
you
um Larry mcfart
um
I do not believe that's your last name
I'm a sacrifice sacrifice is a necessary
virtue that is lost today Japan
um styles he's speaking facts I've done
the same lifted by the wind hey Pearl
I'm convinced I'm convinced the number
of single mom mother families are the
Next Generation simps prove me wrongs
trade dividends um any chance of a
pearly Castle tonight a monkey you stop
the banana girl is a professional victim
lifted by the wind Super Chat Ella star
Horton men make the final decision by
taking all the known variables including
women's views into an account
trade dividends men never enter into a
contract where the other poverty is
incentivized to break the contract Matt
butcher feminism changed everything
through the through all natural Dynamics
off course it seems all of these current
issues stem from it lifted by the wind
thank you for the Super Chat thank you
wolfat daily Leon take a hike brevity is
a lost art Lawrence Bullock didn't the
queen of Sparta cheat on her husband in
exchange for his vote in the Senate not
the kind of partnership I'm looking for
blackest Panther why do 30 percent why
do felons have 30 percent more children
than non-felons zero Fallout bad example
Sparta foul because women got too much
rights and power that is not what
happened that is what happens to every
nation that does that women will want
more and more without accountability the
West is next Black is Panther the banana
on the couch is going downhill slippery
slope it will so we can't can we say
that the lioness's wife led him to all
to her death Tim knew a 50 Super Chat
everyone clap yeah okay
um there is no feminine energy or man
energy men and women operate mainly on
one side of the brain versus the other
so a man uses one side more than the
other same with females they use the
opposite side of the brain mostly from
the male side majority
Larry MC
you said and unchallenged people view
feelings as virtue as the result of a
subconscious gauges that tries to guide
you towards solution Matt delebrio you
caught me with the thumbnail also you're
looking cute today pearly Matt butcher
Shaha something
um opinion on living together can having
her pay rent save a man in the end I
imagine it depends on the local law and
precedence zentians recent Canadian
Court ruling had a millionaire and
ex-girlfriend of several years didn't
cohabitate had her own place but he did
mess up referring to her as his wife a
few times however post breakup she sued
and was awarded fifty thousand dollars a
month Jesus Christ no golden sleep
Alistar Horton all thinks it all depends
if the man thinks that with the lower or
higher head okay guys thank you for the
super chats all of those are going
towards new updates in the studio we're
trying to um have a couple like set
changes like we want to get more
branding like in the middle and have
special cups that everyone hold just
stuff like that for the studio so that's
what all the super chats are going
towards this month okay so
um I think we should react to the next
video ish
um so I actually decided uh just now
that we're gonna react to the 200k
engagement rings I was like I was like
that's a great I didn't even think about
doing this one
oh I think I think their mics are
muted-ish
um
yeah yeah okay
um yeah basically to give you guys the
back story of what happened that day so
um this girl I met I was in LA for a
couple months like last year
um
and I I met her because she was in like
the she kind of talked about like family
like have you ever seen those like
feminine dating coaches but they're not
like feminine at all but I didn't know
that until I met her because it was like
Tick Tock so I was just like oh I'm kind
of starting to look at red pill so let
me just go meet up with her
did like a reaction with her to Kevin
Samuels it's funny everyone loved her
and the Kevin Samuels reaction I did
with her because she was open oh she
also was open to letting her man she she
was yeah oh it's not cheating that's not
cheating oh sorry sorry marriage
distinction yeah yeah you're right
you're right
um but like letting him step out okay
um and so they loved her there
um now no no it wasn't that one-ish oh I
added the new one in the Google Doc
um so if you just want to pull it up if
you bring the Google Doc up
um but basically yeah I I had her
so I was doing a zoom call or not a zoom
call it was like an Instagram live where
people can join I was new to Instagram
live so this was an exciting time in my
life and
um
she starts telling me about her like
dating
and I personally
I look for guys with a job you know but
I didn't realize how high like women's
standards can go at times so I was very
much like shocked at this
but let's see you got it pulled up no
that's the same one-ish it's the second
one YouTube
um the second one yeah
it's the second one no that's the third
one the second one yeah there
okay and then just make it full screen
it's on the screen right okay
um
and you start it from the beginning
so is her dating coach masculine
oh the her dating coach actually seemed
kind of feminine but I just think like
she's have you ever heard of the book
why men love [ __ ]
that's like every feminine like dating
coaches like Playbook it's like raise
your standards while you have less to
offer where like if I was to advise I'd
say put yourself on sale a little bit
like because you have less than ever to
give right you know that's that's what I
would say
um but it'll be like make your standards
Higher and Higher and that's been your
problem the whole time your standards
were just too low
but it's like if Leonardo DiCaprio was
at your door
then I'm sure you would have accepted
that like the issue is what you offer
that's like the the buyers that are
coming just if they're not good that
kind of says something about you yeah
yeah you know that's what I would say
but it's just you got it
no
so you guys haven't seen it before no no
no
do you want to just grab the other Mouse
then
I don't think my algorithm
throws yeah this is kind of cool this is
kind of old
um
oh it's working yeah it's working
um this was like a year ago about I was
a lot nicer then
I'd like to say I was a lot more patient
than I am now
um but
yeah this is
back then it's funny because I re-watch
it and I'm like
I would have said so much more now
but I don't know and so it's 20 20 man
yeah so I was like shocked because I
couldn't
I could I couldn't believe like this was
real like I never heard of someone like
I don't know me and my friends back home
just you kind of just started dating
someone in college and they just you
know and it was just a normal guy from
college and that's who you'd end up
dating for like three years and then you
get married I feel like I know what she
looks at before we even seeing people
with them opinions oh good guy for it
average looking at the low price you
have to bring it above the video capture
device that's why you have to bring you
have to push it up
so is this like a reaction did you did
you click the button of the wedding ring
one no in the middle
foreign
Jess this was just working for you
wasn't it yeah
yeah so it's working but the process is
weird and what's wrong with this one it
was in the exact same thing
okay so I've got a question for you guys
um so say like um
you know getting married to multiple
people became the norm
how would say like the guy gets divorced
by multiple women how would the assets
be divided you know like you know you
know what I'm saying well that's how
would that work that would be
interesting that depends if the country
recognizes if that's an actual marriage
so he could let's just say he he's
legally married to me yeah and then he
has like I don't know so let's say it
became the norm and it was all oh right
okay cool thing well that's the new uh
Arena too that'd be really interesting
right another thing is when you get a
marriage certificate like you could
cohabit like I know let's just say the
cohabitating thing is quite recent but a
marriage certificate it's all
lovey-dovey and woo and everything as
soon as you wanted to get a divorce the
courts and everyone treat it as live
your business partners and there is no
feeling and anything involved if that
makes sense yeah would you be okay with
getting married without like without the
government yeah because I prefer I
prefer that yeah yeah I feel it I feel
like it'd be much better if the
government did not get involved it
should not be a government contract yeah
no because then they treat you as like
you're just too marriage sounds a lot
like a merger and I realized that once
once I was just like oh my God that's so
true yeah until I was just started
watching red pill like because when I
first saw it I was like
like I'm very pro-marriage because like
my parents were married and it just I
saw the benefits like they were able to
build a business and do all this stuff
and I was like why would all these
people so adamantly anti-marriage until
I started like learning about it and I
was like when I found out that you could
lose 25 of your income per kid that's
just crazy that's the number one reason
NBA players go broke I was like
well if I hate it rich I wouldn't want
to get married you offers if you have
five kids
I don't know I'm sure there's some I
don't know I don't think you see stuff
though right yeah I just know
um
I I just know that's what they said in
the video about the child support in
California maybe it's like two is capped
I don't know and then there's like
punitive as well like you're not even
let's just say you haven't been working
for a while but based on your work
history they say this is how much you
will be making whether you like it or
not and that's the other crazy thing
with Jesse Williams Oh okay um did you
hear about that no I did so he wanted to
switch careers
so he he did Gray's Anatomy that's my oh
he's my childhood Crush thank you shout
out Jesse Williams that was he
um he did Gray's Anatomy though he's
like the pretty boy in Gray's Anatomy
and he wanted to go into theater and he
was a multi like he made a ton of money
in Gray's Anatomy and then he went to
theater but I guess you still have to
pay the same child support even if you
switch jobs so he had to go to court to
get it switched but I guess like you
probably know about this like guys go
broke in the process yeah he didn't he
was a multi-millionaire so he was fine
but it's crazy to even like even a
multi-millionaire the they took most of
his income like 5K per month roughly
Jesus it just seems like they're just
being punished punished punished it's
just yeah and it's like and it's like
even when they don't get married they
still get punished by living with her
yeah and then girls will say oh I'm
afraid of being left high and dry but
you're like
he
'd be afraid you're gonna leave and take
half isn't the most wealthy most wealthy
women
um due to like the the most wealthy due
to divorce in most cases yeah that is
wow
that's like the most wealthy woman on
the planet it's because of divorce yeah
which is like it's interesting because
then they can claim that they're
self-made because they can invest in a
business and stuff like that just like I
made my own mind is like bear hat
oh yeah so you you existed
I think like what's personally I find
really sad is that basically people oh
it's okay yeah I think are you getting
it yeah you got it okay is that like
this is supposed to be you know this is
supposed to be a beautiful thing coming
and finding someone that you want to
spend time with that you feel
comfortable with together you know
that's the thing like
everyone has different flavors right
some people they do want to have
multiple partners I've seen people with
polygamous relationships and they're
very healthy they they just they just
put everything up on the table and say
this is what we want are we happy with
that and if we're not can we come back
to the table and talk about it that's
what you should do and I find that it's
really sad that there's a lot of
examples of people who basically come in
with
with the with with maybe like they I
don't I don't want to think this but I
know that some people go into it with
the with the intention of doing harm and
I think that's so bad because then it's
definitely specific it's an agenda
though because I think I think that's
more from women than men yeah and and
because there's more benefit for women I
think men we're just we're just
creatures where we look at things like
is it a fair deal like marriage to men
does not seem like a fair deals do you
do you think the laws will ever get
better for men
they they're in this country is there a
tide switching or do you think it's
getting worse in this country yeah I'll
say in this country man it just got
worse I think because in April of this
year they introduced no fault divorces I
don't know if you're aware of that what
does that mean does that mean no fault
divorces basically means that uh just to
get a divorce I don't need to State the
reason why I want to divorce so for
example before
um before no fault divorces there's a
fault divorce so I can only get a
divorce if I can prove my
my husband or my wife was guilty of
something which is like he deserted me
or she deserted me there was adultery or
whatever abuse and now I don't have to
give any reason whatsoever whether my
husband likes it or not I can just go to
the school and just like yeah I want to
divorce and then they'll give it to you
so the statistics are what did you say
of your experienced a 15 men right the
initiating divorce
85 women 15 men and you still they
introducing no yes guess who was
championing no fault divorce women yeah
of course yeah of course it's easy peasy
you know just it's so sad but um
so for what I was gonna say so if they
go through with that process do they
still get the same amount of money
exactly that's the thing they do no no
what happens is if there's no fault if
you go for a no-fault divorce so it's
like you can get the divorce without you
know who if if you've committed adultery
that's the judge will say that none of
my business and whatever but when it
comes to dividing up assets then your
fault is actually brought up because
then it's like a contributing factor
then they they're forced to look into
that because now you're fighting over 50
50 you know it's like it's misleading
well they don't talk about adultery like
if the girl like 25 of marriages are
sexless yeah so if he cheats like if you
aren't sleeping with him like what do
you think he's doing but then but then
that's your own fault if you get cheated
on and you're not having sex with him
that is your own fault that is your own
but the thing is it's like if if the
court if the courts doesn't don't
recognize that obviously women are going
to use that today and it's it's really
sad it's like how can the courts not
recognize that sex is not about
uh the differences between men and women
with regards to to put it bluntly how
horny men are compared to our horny
women know how how much we want to have
sex compared to how much women have when
we get to the point we're honest because
the courts are never going to be honest
the government's not going to be honest
women can't seem to Fathom the fact that
we enjoy
having sex I think it's just telling
women straight that if you're insecure
about him being Pleasant it's okay if
you're insecure it's fine right like I
think women like I'm not in school like
just the thing is you're not trying to
be in school you're just insecure
because of jealousy or whatever but if
you see how it is actually a benefit
if you hold your phone up you go on
Instagram and scroll through
women are taking the complete opposite
that like if he does this go if he does
yeah of course because they won't admit
that they're insecure because who would
do that would your girl be open to that
hell no oh no she wants her right now
probably
yeah okay we're gonna we're gonna watch
the video now
um so this goes back to
right you said you got it okay
and then start it from the beginning
yeah there you go
that sort of sort of space it's been
brought back you
back let's celebrate like I want to take
you out and I'm like oh how many how
many dates have you guys gone on one
okay yeah we went on one right before I
left that was our first first date it's
a date
go ahead sorry so now we'll go I guess
on a second one
but he's kind of short he's only like
five nine
oh that's you're you're what like five
nights I'm five eight that's tall enough
right not really yeah manifesting a tall
man one of the other guys I'm talking to
is six foot seven
oh wow okay yeah
uh and we'll be going out soon it's just
a matter of like scheduling we just
haven't been able to like link on the
schedules we both work a lot
um
oh there's another guy who I just made
this whole take a tick tock about who
was like all about me asked me out
calling me all these pet names my love
and all this [ __ ] and then we're talking
and I was like oh you have the vaccine
right and he was like no I was like
you're not vaccinated and you want to go
out with me I'm like I'm not going out
with you you're not vaccinated what you
[ __ ] me kissing you you're not
vaccinated really oh I wouldn't care I
don't care in too many Arenas where you
have to be vaccinated like I work at a
yoga studio where we're requiring proof
of vaccination that's where I have right
now holding all this laundry and do all
these music festivals where they're
requiring proof of vaccination and to me
it's so much deeper than just like do
you or don't you it's about that like I
don't want to have that debate with you
right like clearly if we don't view it
the same way we're not in alignment
right
so would you not would you not date
someone that was different than you like
politically no I wouldn't what are what
are your standards like what are your
requirements for a guy
I mean politically I definitely want us
to have the same view you know I'm a
black woman right so I'm not going to
date like a white Republican that would
just be a headache like why would we do
that to ourselves
we okay friends we wouldn't travel in
the same circles and we don't view this
the world the same way
use the world the same as me and even if
you're not black but you're white and
you like get and understand the black
struggle fine that's fine
um but yeah I definitely want them to
have the same political views as me
because it's just why bother and having
those arguments okay I'm just gonna turn
into a fight later
yeah so what like what else
uh
uh well they have to have a car this
other guy who didn't have a vaccine he
didn't have a car I was like how are you
coming to take me out you don't have a
car you know I'm not driving anywhere
yeah
so that's like minimum requirement you
have to have a car
um I've also realized that I want
someone that has like some sort of
creative or like job and entertainment
like I have
um you have to be very ambitious because
I am very ambitious I wanted to be able
to like you know we'll spend our days or
whatever separately and then at the end
of the night I want us to be able to
come together and talk about all of the
exciting things that happen in each of
our lives right like okay this other guy
was like well I'm not rich I'm a regular
guy and I was like that's fine but like
I'm not a regular girl like I'm I'm not
so like if you're if you are gonna date
me like either you have to be able to
handle that or you yourself also wants
to not be like regular like I don't
think like just an average person like
that to be scoring Okay so
is there like do you care okay would you
be cool if a guy that makes less money
but he's very he's a hard worker like
he's ambitious
yeah okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him
you wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring I'm getting an eight
carat cushion cut vintage engagement
ring if you make forty five thousand
dollars a year it would take what
four years no eight years but how much I
don't know anything about Rings how much
how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a 200 000
are you insane
my ring has to Sparkle from across the
streets you have blind people that's so
superficial that's like so superficial
but it's about so much more than that
it's about the fact that you can afford
that right I go to yoga with this girl
who has an eight carat diamond
engagement ring yeah the weed company
and drives an Audi so it's about more
than just it's about the fact that you
can afford that okay well I'm just
thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because I'm telling you know but not not
in a good way not in a good way I'm
telling you like my dad would if my mom
asked for that from my dad my dad would
have told her to go find a new boyfriend
because there's no way in hell he was
going to spend two hundred thousand
dollars on an engagement ring and that's
something
no and that's a multi-millionaire in the
top half a percent who had 10 kids my
mom never
he said he's built to the becoming that
he wasn't that originally right he
wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like like to me that's
like such an unwise investment to spend
200k
diamonds appreciate
oh my gosh no no oh my God no that's
like I would rather put that in a
college fund for our kids or like yeah
they'll have that too
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know really yeah like I know
for me like I told you like my my status
is going up like I just did a music
festival where I made 30 grand over the
weekend in one weekend you know what I
mean like I need somebody who can be on
that level right but the problem is like
guys don't care about your money
right there I I know but it doesn't like
you know like I'm just I think you're
gonna miss out on a lot of guys with
like this like to me these are like
crazy high standards so today I listen
to my dating coach she said you do not
get your expectation you get your
minimum standard mm-hmm
is your dating coach married yes and
she's a baby and her wedding ring is at
least five carats yeah and her man is
rich excuse me okay you know he herself
makes like 30 to 50 Grand a month
coaching women in love
I mean good luck if that like works for
you I just like to me that sounds like a
200k engagement ring like I think like
guys are gonna hear that and be like no
no no you just have to have the man
who's okay with maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
okay but I'm I'm just thinking like like
I I know but those guys that are making
like like that amount of money like
I think they typically want like the
young like 21 22 year olds
I don't think so
what
I'm 30 so I'm not that old I'm actually
no I'm age to be wiped up by somebody
who's like in their 40s and like ready
to be serious and start popping out
babies a 21 year old unless you're Kylie
Jenner is realistically too young to be
like popping out kids
like you're too young
yeah I mean that's just I'm sorry the
200 000 like that's crazy to me that's
like
oh my gosh I cannot believe that's crazy
someone that can make that amount of
money in a shorter period of time like
somebody who would say musical artist
right a new producer somebody who's in
entertainment somebody who's on a TV
show somebody who does like concerts and
tours that amount of money isn't the
same to them you know what I mean what
do you mean
like say I was dating somebody like a
pretty easy right okay he makes 150 000
minimum per show then that's what he
makes it a show yeah so if he does a
couple shows the 200 Grand to him he
won't even feel it
no but like this is something coming
from someone like I've been in a
relationship with a guy that was worth
over a million
like I but I would never in a million
years ask him to spend 200k on a ring
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like I'm not entitled to
his money I mean
here's the thing if I can afford it
myself
I I would want you to be able to get it
for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah I guess like we kind of probably
have different like views on like
spending habits because to me I'm like I
would even if I had the money I would
never spend that on a ring
foreign
person right so it's like you're not
going to need to be buying me diamonds
for every anniversary for jewelry all
the time like get me my ring
and that's it I don't really need much
help
hi oh my gosh
oh yeah
are you okay
it's horrible
I'm sorry but that is horrible she's
number one missing the point she's
looking at things
really really doesn't I'm sorry she's
going to be in a very unhappy
relationship if she finds that person
it's all based on whatever is exterior
there's there she doesn't care about
anything deeper and that's that's I'm
very I feel sorry for her she doesn't
actually know what's important and
I I really feel for the men like
guys who have so much they're working so
hard they're trying to prove themselves
because society makes them
because you have to make your way inside
it you have to do
so much to prove yourself these days
and to have this girl come here and just
completely belittle you on the internet
these are good men out there
and and they don't just they they they
don't deserve you you don't even deserve
a McDonald's from them
I'm sorry but
you
it's not about the dollar sign it's
about the intention
I would love even if who cares about the
food if a guy takes me to McDonald's and
then buys me a meal
amazing
I love McDonald's
like what's wrong with that it's the
intention it's the fact that he
made made a point and said hey I've got
this
I want to take you out I want to get you
the meal that's the point it's not about
how much it is it's about the fact that
someone went out of their way and they
wanted to do a wonderful gesture for you
that's the point and to sit here and
demand an eight carat ring so that
someone next door can see you across the
road well one year clearly you've got
insecurities because you feel like
that's what's going to add value to you
because it's not I'm interested because
it's quite interesting that upsets you
um because that's why I asked you well
I'm glad you clarified because at the
beginning you said you feel sorry for
her then you said you feel sorry for men
because
of the bad
I feel sorry for men because I mean
right
remember I said before we even watched I
knew what a woman looked like
and I think we can all categorically
agree without being harsh that is a bang
average looking lady so that's the
problem
your bank average looking lady with I
want this I want this I want this I want
this
and I think she listed one thing that
she offers she made 30 grand over the
weekend you told her
men don't care about money she then went
on to say
but it's what I care about but it's what
she has nothing to oh she has a list of
requirements and she can't even offer
the first thing that men appreciate
which is what she looks like
which to me I know beauty is now
Beholder but that's a bang average
looking lady I don't know what you think
you can be honest all right
so if she was a very incredibly pretty
lady
at least it adds some sort of substance
at least had some sort of I mean level
we could say about cool she she she's in
a top 10 percent of ladies in the world
she's asking for this crap at least off
the bat she's pretty but to give all of
those requirements and to be oh God
honestly I think the fact that you know
she felt like she could share that and
like felt like she had ground to stand
on is crazy like the fact that you know
you can um she felt she feels like she's
like
she can't expect that and you know she
was saying stuff like um
oh yeah um
you get like the minimum expectation I
think it was something along those lines
right
no you get to have cats and probably die
alone and I have no like ill intent
towards this woman but seriously if
realistically if you are acting like
that anyone who's got that money is not
going to spend that money in that way
because it's it's dumb it doesn't make
sense and the fact that she felt
comfortable to say that in public is
just like what is it Contour you know
what I mean what is going on because
that is delusional more common than you
think as well by the way that that might
seem extreme it's actually not a lot of
women think
how common would you say that is
um I think more in America that's coming
in the UK do you think it's more common
in America yeah yeah okay
um yeah
I would say it's uncommon here though
yeah
I think they vocalize it more in America
yeah
I appreciating us in a way because at
least they're honest about it but yeah
in the UK I think that's honesty or
delusion delusion a mixture of both to
be honest
yeah because it lets the men know who to
avoid
exactly what if what if a woman comes to
you that's where everybody well if a
woman comes to you and says that and you
tell her you're delusional and she's
like well I don't want to lower my
standards to be able to get some random
guy I'm going to keep my standards like
this what would you guys say to her um I
I'm very much I say I is I don't really
uh
cut out you know the the rough Parts I
just kind of I don't beat around the
bush I'm just direct to it I just tell
her straight up like if you're expecting
this then you're not gonna get far with
what you want and you need to
re-evaluate and reassess
everything if you think
to this extreme and also like share the
example I gave earlier like the shingle
mother
obviously I'm not going to be like too
harsh because she's got at the end of
the day she got a kid to look after but
like you gotta tell him like you can't
you need to humble yourself you know you
can't you can't go around expecting and
like expecting all this while like
you're burdening the man on the other
side of the coin well it's kind of like
if you're a used car and you're asking
new prices you can say that like no one
you know the the only buyers that are
going to come or the ones that can
afford you but if no buyers come then
what is that leave you should be on
discount
on I don't understand why it's such a
bad thing to be on sale I'm on sale from
22.00
[Music]
me and Jess are on a two for one special
Sister Sister Sister Wives vote
yes he's delusional man but yeah it's
crazy what was your reaction
I had to watch that again but anyway but
uh yeah okay she used to blame because
she's she's allowing herself to you know
run away with all these Fantastical
ideas but also the dating coach I think
the dating coach is taking her for a
ride and it's just like I'm gonna just
leave you to it and get the money and
then now she's defending if the dating
coach actually said I want you to
actually meet this man who is willing to
give 200k whatever then that's something
but she I think she's definitely been
played no I looked up the dating coach
she was hotter hotter girls get better
results surprising and I'm just like and
it's so sad because she she's the the
dating coach is making her believe yeah
you can get what I know but what I've
got that's what girls will say like okay
for example Sierra right in a way she
she raised her price a bit and she she
ended up with like I'd say Russell is a
better husband than future but that that
works if you're hot
I mean maybe we can afford to do that
yeah that's what I'm saying like I'm not
saying I don't think it works the
majority of the time everyone looks at
Russell as a samp but the girls that it
works out for you by the way are what I
think he's the same yeah yeah but the
girls that it works out for are
extremely hot that's not gonna look work
for the average girl and so they'll look
at girls that do that that are hotter
than them and think oh if I do that then
I could but it's like nah it ain't you I
also think so um the uh you know women
giving women advice a lot of the time
tends to be um
telling them what they want to hear
rather than what they need to hear I uh
I honestly feel like that's the way
things are going whether it's like go
you attend you know like that's that's
mostly the case never true right
um tens are perfect and I happen to
believe that perfect and everything so
um you there's always a way about
yourself so you know and also about it
um you know saying not like they can
they can get like the these high earning
men it's just it's the same thing it's
just telling them what they want to hear
because they want that in a man so the
advice is oh yeah
um you're writing one in that you
deserve that B all that you know
[ __ ] when at the end of the day they
need to hear is you need a reality check
and you need to chart your adults just
like you ain't going anywhere do you
think that's all women like what we saw
in the video or do you think it's a
certain type of ethnicity or demographic
of women this is a question for
everybody I mean I could keep it 100 and
say that's a more of a problem in the
black community I think in my opinion I
can't speak to that I'm not gonna hide
his way it's my community we have some
problems man yeah yeah it's facts it's
facts we got higher requirements at the
end of the day this is what I'm I'm very
passionate about this actually because
um I travel the world I've been
everywhere and anywhere I go to black
people on the bottom when it comes to
any Financial requirement any Financial
metric we're always at the bottom yet we
require
the highest thing so yeah in my
community in the black community in a
day in community in the black community
in the dating world as well we have a
lot of issues we've got to deal with
keep it 100
foreign
have you guys ever had to tell a friend
that they're shooting too high how'd
that go for you
she she knew oh she knew she knew and uh
yeah so she was just quiet did she
adjust
oh yeah I think she did yeah she ended
up because I think she was forced to
like like that that woman yeah
she wants a real actual man that doesn't
sound so stupid that we're saying this
but to the point when she's not getting
that actual connection with an actual
human being because she's always
fantasizing
um I think she'll be forced to Humble
herself and that's the thing when she's
forced to Humble herself and lower her
standards it'll be too late for her and
she's just gonna whatever she can get
basically well she um
now I've seen our Tech talks recently
it's like the same yeah oh my yeah
they're not yeah oh God but and it's sad
though because she's never had a
boyfriend either
no no no
she never had a boyfriend not woman on
the video yeah she never had a boyfriend
I don't doubt that somehow yeah but
that's why like that's why she almost
seemed unrealistic like delusional about
what like a relationship is I might feel
sorry for a little bit after hearing
that because now she's going to dating
coach when she should coach herself like
as a you know get experience I'm sorry
for someone who put their themselves in
there I said a little bit because I feel
like she's she's
actually I don't know she also had the
cheek to say um
I'm not that interested in jewelry even
after she recorded 200. she was like
yeah but you know what that's it right
I'll be made yeah
yeah I hope that you don't require
anything like no presents for ever 200k
oh my God I think like because I did say
that I feel sorry for her so I think
I'll answer that question from my point
of view I think it's coming from a place
where
I think she doesn't know better and
she's on her journey
of whatever it is and I feel sad that
yeah I I I pity her it's it's I I I I I
would I would hope that people would
find more meaningful things in a
relationship Beyond and an unrealistic
number I don't care at all because I
just think that's an excuse like you're
30 years old you don't you don't know I
don't put you [ __ ]
I can see that yeah that's the thing
like men men hit reality hard they're
rejected by that girl at 16 in math
class she lets the whole class know but
she turns you down because she looks
better if she could turn down more guys
so reality hits men Hardware women it's
like we choose to live in delusion and
it's a choice because clearly if she's
never had a boyfriend there's been no
takers I'm not saying that's why I'm I'm
not saying that I'm relieving her of her
own like I'm not saying that she
shouldn't take responsibility for her
life and her choices and the way she
presented herself I agree with yeah it's
a it's just my personal way of reacting
to things I understand I'm just a very
empathetic person so
I I think I would want everyone to be on
a great place I wouldn't want anyone to
be discriminated or
being treated poorly and that's why I'm
upset because
I I really feel for people who are being
somehow told you're not good enough
because you can't get me I'm sorry it's
all right that's just that's just me I
it's not I'm not generalizing for
everyone that's just a personal thing
and I feel it's really sad that these
people exist this is what I think it's
important
um see I'm not mad I'll keep it 100 if
you as a male getting upset about that
I would have a different reaction to you
the fact that you're a female again I've
said that I can understand that and this
is why I also encourage men not to be
too emotional because emotional men
would accept what she's asking for and
end up laughing her and yes the Snowball
Effect you you you have a woman out
there asking for a million requirements
and if you're a man that feels sorry for
them type of women you start wife and
them type of women encouraging more
women to have a list of even more
requirements and then Men start weapons
also it's important that I think we
understand the difference that you're a
female getting upset by that that's fine
if there's a man getting upset by that
that would almost encourage him to
accept what she's asking for do you
think if you've said this before to
bring back bullying do you think if she
was bullied bruh it would solve so many
problems it would solve so no I'm
serious I'm serious none of y'all have
been humbled you know what my brother
told me I had a big nose until I was 22.
22. and you know what it humbled me okay
I don't know I have a great nose right
thank you thank you but but literally my
brother my brother from like the time I
was a kid but you'd always tell me I was
ugly and honestly I feel like it kept me
down to earth no I'm not off
yeah that would be better right good and
you know what I was I was fat
I got on the treadmill you know what I
mean that's your problem bro that's what
I'm saying I'm like if someone was like
that's how to say when I watch it back
I'm like I wish I was a little bit more
direct but I was in shock I don't know
if you saw my face I was like
Missy it's you though you use that to
actually fuel yourself to do the right
thing instead of feeling sorry for
yourself yeah no that's what that's what
I think too I mean the problem with that
is um every person in turn realizes and
deals with trauma differently so it's
some people do it exactly the way you do
it so you you enter you actually make
into Fuel and you make it useful the
problem is there are a lot of people who
don't and that's what we end up with
situation where suicide happens because
people cannot get out of it and it
spirals out of control and I think
that's that's the thing like everyone's
an individual you walk process your
trauma differently
um
I was bullied and it was horrible and
yes I understand that
the bully was bullied as well it was a
cycle she then felt that in order to
feel better about herself she's going to
bully her her own her own people who are
under her and
and she was Infamous for it and it was
it's so sad it got so many people
mentally and well work related stress
people who had to go people just left
because they it was it wasn't well and I
have I know there were people that I
worked with
who still cannot go back to that
workplace because if they're near it she
goes into a panic attack and I think in
general tough times build tough people
perfect that's what I think like I mean
like yeah some people take process it
differently but I just think in general
we're in a place in society where no one
can handle criticism ever and it's like
any I mean how do you think I deal with
the comments all the time I have girls
roasting every part of my appearance
right now my answer I don't care yeah my
brothers did that for me the first year
the same people that preached posi uh
body positivity yeah it's the whales the
whales are coming the whales are coming
like I just think that tough times breed
tough people
it does um but I think again that that
depends on the personality
and I personally have and I still deal
with mentally and well patients and I
can tell you it's it's very sad at the
the different stories that go to the
horrors they've lived through from
childhood and onwards and
the honest truth is you cannot just tell
them to suck it up and deal with it
because it is trauma and
what else do you do though like like
because it's like it's kind of like if
you don't like like what what are you
supposed to do I mean I understand like
you go so that's maybe you talk about it
can I ask a question so then like you go
through the trauma you talk about it but
then it's like what now like the only
the only thing you can do is move
forward so it's about realizing so for
example the idea of triggering right I
don't understand what the whole idea of
trigger warning is I think as you say
it's like trying to cater to a certain
amount of people who can't deal with the
fact that they're triggered by something
the important thing about being
triggered is that actually whatever is
triggering you is a statement it's
neutral and you are being triggered
because you for some reason have some
type of trauma because of that so
for example it's very personal but one
of the things I saw online uh different
uh YouTuber the guys were saying exactly
the same if you're a girl over if you've
if you are a girl who
have been single for a certain amount of
time that's a red flag
and the first time I heard that I was
triggered I was like oh my God like what
and and rather than react which a lot of
people do a lot of girls then they lash
out and they're horrible I say to myself
no no why are you triggered
and I was like because he's he's saying
truth because guess what when you meet
someone
first impression is your innate alarm
system you need that to try and you know
protect yourself it's part it's natural
to have an alarm now of course it's
important to then
when you get to know someone because you
can't always judge a book by the cover
so it's important to take the red flags
but don't run with it and take it beyond
that all and so I asked myself why on
Earth are you triggered
because you shouldn't be it's a
statement and I said it's because I've
been single for a while and guess what
it's triggering me because I don't want
to I I don't want to be single if you
know it's mostly and and this is the
thing so I realized hey so well what are
you gonna do about it well why don't you
work on yourself why don't you work on
your femininity why don't you work on
making yourself the best version you can
so that maybe when you when the right
person come in then you're at the right
energy to be with that person if you
notice most people are triggered by the
truth like you said so if someone says
something about it that's not true that
wouldn't trigger me personally I don't
think if someone says oh you're this
you're done it's not true okay like if
someone if someone called you short you
wouldn't care
but I don't know because like I always
think about when we talk about trauma
like what is trauma because all
throughout all of human history we're
all involved in like Wars starvations
plagues and now it's like we talk about
like trauma being okay you were bullied
a little bit as a kid like I just feel
like our ancestors would look at us and
laugh it's because because throughout
all of human history we had horrible
lives yeah and nobody had to like talk
like go to a psychologist and talk about
it I honestly feel like um it's because
we've started catering to the people who
are traumatized so like I'm not uh I'm
not saying they shouldn't get help what
I'm saying is that having things like
trigger warnings right there's stuff
like exposure therapy for a reason but
if we start like saying oh yeah this
person can't hear that then it's just
gonna like set them up to be triggered
for it you know what I mean like so if
it becomes normalized and you hear it
day to day then like you're not going to
be triggered and if it still triggers
you that's when you have to go and seek
therapy right to better yourself for me
it's really frustrating to see
mental health and Trauma get users
almost like buzzwords in today's society
because I've seen it in my family I've
seen it firsthand people going through
some real [ __ ] so when people just like
start using that oh I'm going through
mental health I'm going through this
like like from an ex-boyfriend it's like
trauma's supposed to be from like War
exactly not not an X that like cheated
on you exactly when we use them examples
people like will say I think because
every society every every generation
does a new set of problems right so it's
like yes we have different problems as
to problems that they have 50 years ago
but we need to understand that the world
we live in is much better than it was
100 years ago like we need to understand
that and embrace it and stop using
everything as like because I think I
think the problem with it is like my
brother went through mental health and I
think when I was watching him go for it
it was a 10-year 10-year spent him
getting better and worse and on and off
and the best advice I gave at first I
was very sympathetic and I was like oh
don't worry we're here to help you when
he got better
is when I was harsh with him I said look
no one's here to save you no bro you
keep doing this keep doing that that's
you bro that's when he started to
realize when I was more empathetic with
him and sympathetic with him he was
getting worse because he had someone to
kind of lean on and just I think the
same way like the last like breakup I
was in it was kind of like because I
really only talked to my family about
that sort of stuff um for the most part
and my dad was just like shut up
he's like shut up it's over yeah move on
and I was just like damn yeah
did you die no I did I was like you know
what he's right he's right if anything
you actually you know you can move on
with your life because you'll never get
it back the time that we waste yeah
that's what that's what my dad said
that's the best thing I think one of the
best things look forward let's my dad
always tells me he's like look forward
you can't you literally can't change the
past and even even my dad healed like a
tough childhood and growing up people
would like there were comments that he
should like go to therapy about it or
whatever and his mindset was just like
why it's over like what am I what's
what's talking about it gonna do like
you want me to talk about my problems
you know what's interesting though he
was doing something called radical
acceptance and that's something that's
done in therapy so he just did his own
therapy so therapy is not like let's
just build different yeah because look
so many people everybody's different
it's not like therapy just being in a
room and the same results yeah he did
his own therapy and you just have to
radically accept things are the way they
are and I just move on or I accept that
okay maybe I I got bullied because I'm
ugly yeah I have to accept that I'm not
a 10. yeah move on it's kind of like a
soft topic I don't know if you know when
Morgan Freeman he done he um I think he
got asked in like a in an interview
they're like oh how do we get over
racism and he said stop talking about it
and then I was at first it's about to
when I first saw that about eight years
ago I was like what the hell is this guy
talking about black man on TV saying
stop talking about race is it not when I
got old and I realized hold on he's back
on because it's just like we're talking
about what's wrong we're like oh or
mental health like you get over things
by just moving on cracking on moving
forward if we all think about our
darkest and deepest times I think about
them and when I think about them it
makes me feel worse I don't want to talk
about I want to crack and then as soon
as I got that harsh reality bro no one's
here to save you
keep moving that's when I felt better I
just feel like life is so short you're
never going to be younger than you are
now you're never gonna have more energy
than you are now like and that's what I
don't know I always try to get things
done like as quickly as I can because
you just never know how much time you
got left and it's like you're gonna
spend the time you have worried about
some [ __ ] that happened yesterday I
can't change it yeah I think the thing
is is that where all of us here are more
on the Practical side even the girls so
yes of course I'm the same as you uh but
I from my experience as someone as a
more of a clinician I've realized that
there are different there are different
personality their dis personality
disorders there are people who think
very differently from us and the problem
you see them in feminism is that the
problem is that they don't know how to
deal with the trauma so it turns into
hate it turns into feminism it turns
into trying to Exile an entire
gender that's that's that's the problem
because certain people I get certain
people are great with dealing with
trauma they know how to deal with
themselves some people can't and the
problem with them is that they can't or
choose not to
you don't think because again throughout
all of human history like we had Wars we
had famine we had all of these horrible
horrible things like you don't think on
some level it's a choice
I think the difficulty as well is that
part of it is for example precise orders
um they are actually cultivated from
childhood and they are very very
prevalent in broken families people who
have the wrong type of father and mother
figures and it's very sad because what
happens is the child they don't they
learn they don't learn how to
basically be an adult and and deal with
things an adult way so they do very if
you see it basically they're very
childish in the way they do things they
they thought anger Tantrums
because I think this is important yeah
don't we don't whoa I got the answer
really when I ask anyway don't we don't
we think that adding all these different
personality disorders is the problem
I've got because I've seen it as a kid
so I went to a normal school you know
rough kids could whatever was a bit of a
mixture and
an interruptive or dismissive child oh
he's got ADHD this other kid he's got
that he's got that but it's like we it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy you you
label a 12 year old with ADHD he's gonna
grow he's gonna I've seen kids use as an
excuse I've got ADHD I can't control
myself or I got this because they've
been diagnosed at such a young age with
such issues it's like you just live you
just live on it's true it's like you
can't you can't even with ADHD you can't
do anything about it otherwise then put
yourself on Ritalin from like being a
child which doesn't seem like because
honestly they um like I'm pretty
energetic you know yeah yeah and I've
been like people have diagnosed me and I
would say diagnosed because it's so easy
to get diagnosed I don't even I don't
even count it but it's like but I was
like what am I gonna do I could take
drugs and it's like you don't sleep on
the drugs so I was like I don't want to
do that and my other choice is to make
excuses and say that's everything and I
just just like no I'll just be normal
the other thing is that there's um you
might know more about this about the DSM
and the fact that mental illnesses
there's a there's a debate in what
actually is a mental illness like a an
actual one or are you just catering to
the patient if the patient says I'm
feeling this way
uh I don't know there was a I'm not sure
what it means but some sorry I can't
forgot I forgot what the actual term is
but if a woman's been abused
from grape mentioned it first time
um then that there's some sort of uh
she's she has a mental illness that says
that she's she wanted that to happen or
something like really some it just I
don't know if you're familiar what I'm
talking about
are you saying that like
from what they learned from their
parents or from past experiences them
again for it in the future no girl oh
girls are turned on by grape scenes like
in movie like yeah no I swear are you
for real no I'm sure it's like a whole
thing on Reddit yeah so psychiatrists
are now saying is that really but
they're saying that's a mental disorder
I don't I think that's Evolution
slightly as like effed up as that is
what happened to evolutionarily right
they would they would take the woman
kill the kids
yeah so I mean that's my guess but I
heard it that's that's what I thought of
was like throughout history that's what
like happened that was just blowing my
mind I had no clue about that I don't
know they would take that's what
happened in tribes like they would they
would kill the man kill the kids take
the women if the old women were gone too
yeah and then damn people you saying
women are turned on by groups yeah but
like there's some women out there that
are turned on I mean that's the number
one we had an only a male only fans
model on the show that's his number one
request oh my god wow yeah grape yeah
and that's that's fun because yeah
seriously I don't know why I I just I
don't
yeah I don't know so when next time when
that exception comes up maybe we can
take that what do you mean which one the
exception of what if she was graped but
there's like looks like that because in
a way I'll try to explain it it's
horrible but
um so children children are
impressionable right and unfortunately
if they experience something like that
at a very young age because they're
impressionable they learn that maybe
that's how I would get love
and so
daddy treats me well when that happens I
get nice things afterwards
um so they end up subconsciously taking
that on and they end up it's not it's
not logical but they do because that's
part of Grooming
you you basically set someone in you
calibrate them in in a way that doesn't
make any sense to someone who has a has
a normal upbringing but the the reality
of these people is that it's it's very
sad that's the thing like for us it's
very difficult to understand because we
were I think I think we were brought up
in a safe household
people like that aren't and the problem
is that I wasn't I wasn't I think I came
out no not every single person does
that's what I'm saying some people do
normal women normal girls use the you
try to fit themselves in actual victims
yeah so I agree with you so that's what
I'm saying so certain personality
disorders actually so when I'm a
clinician and I'm looking at a person
the person will tell me whatever they
are in an examination we not only listen
to what they say we have to actually
interpret it okay so we don't take their
word as face value they tell us whatever
it is but we it we we we're judging them
everything we judge what they wear we
judge how they look we judge how they
present themselves what they're saying
what their intentions are and we will
actually say like this person is
manipulative we'll say it because we
that's the point we have to figure out
that person and it's it's a very very
uncomfortable thing to do that the thing
is like it exists I don't I don't know
what kind of Mission you are
um so I'd rather not oh no you don't you
don't have to understand but um every
psychologist that I know that's like a
girl is literally nuts and I would not
trust her diagnosing anybody like every
single one I've not met one that's that
I wouldn't um and I just think there's
some like flaws in the system when it
comes to diagnosing people because
everyone's diagnosed with something
um so just real quick
um anyone that took the train I'm going
to read super chats but if you took the
train um I would take off your
headphones and go now because the last
one's gonna go I just will let you out
other than that everyone so if you want
to any of anyone else um can stay and
you can give your final thoughts after I
read super chats but but there's a bunch
so I'm going to take a second so if you
want to just tell people anything last
words before you go
um thanks everyone
um I hope it was an interesting time and
um looking forward to the new place okay
yeah thanks for coming just to let you
out so guys thank you so much for all of
these super chats I'm a bunch have come
in so I'm just gonna read them real
quick
um silly silly sausage girl in the video
needs a cucumber toy that runs on diesel
when all the fuel and with all with fuel
prices these days good luck girls
self-sabotage at such a horrible rate
Pearl you need to come to Ireland again
I did go to Ireland that was fun lifted
by the wind
um the egocentrist the egocentricity of
Western women is astounding more kite
when the girl in the middle is ready to
to be to not be singled please DM me DM
me I'm liking the thoughtfulness and
sensitivity from her um her Instagram is
in my um oh wait no it's not sorry okay
she won't damn you
um maybe comment maybe comment your IG
and she'll see it later
um 90 free tote please invite empathy
girl always is Ozzy
um appreciate her tears I really get
that she's in touch I really I really
get she's touched with reality her
Distinction on psych masculine feminine
and self-awareness while open to Pearl's
ideas example of healthy positive
relationship with men rare please invite
back monkey you stop I told y'all she's
a professional victim bring back
bullying how how are you 33ing still
crying over something like that 93 Tope
women are com something the tallest nail
gets smack
arquis kicks Empire 50 Super Chat yay
questions for the ladies on the panel
why are so many women in today's society
openly opening
opting to to kill off children and to
neglect motherhood then turn around and
demand provider things from men stoic
masculinity thank you for the Super Chat
Brit Cormier the women that wants a 200k
ring is going to be a side chick until
she dies or change her attitude the men
that can spend on a or not putting that
on her finger Vic guns Dangerous Minds
2022 Pearl saves the inner city dating
Community I'm black an old school
classic man it's so good to see young
people doing good things for society get
them Pearl 90 free-toe pie I love the
I'm in love with the sensitive girl
single hit me up Doug MPA the girl that
wants a ring like that talking to Pearl
is an American black woman as a whole
pay attention black men have dealt with
this for the past 30 years Edgar Rays
I'm 5'8 and I'm considered short
especially when a woman like that say
that meanwhile my doctor tells me I'm
average height and I'm completely fine
with it men like me accept it tall women
don't want us and we're not intimidated
Cole Pearl if we're talking about
healthy that is healthy that why do so
many women eat cheeseburgers when it
makes you fatty Sean Rowe the that's a
damn good woman on the left the banana
isn't bad also and respect to you I
don't why do they say banana she said it
at the stall it's a joke but she
identified [ __ ] I was so con I forgot
about that yeah and respect to you Pearl
keep doing what you're doing um thank
you for Super Chat so just Sean JG
Aussie both women need to make
distinctions between human nature
masculine feminine and her personal
experiences parents and exes but also
open to Pearl's ideas example of a
healthy positive relationship with men
please invite her back ATA I qualify
that's our member of the week yay I
qualify for the Asian one but does she
date latinos
Eros no Lasco Alpha mothers make beta
sons and blame men for not being leaders
Kevin Samuels beta males are the ones
advancing Humanity modern women don't
think long term are for the Next
Generation Vic guns Pearl thank you for
what you were doing keep it up Pearl ish
saragar V just the dream team that was a
hundred dollar Super Chat Nathaniel
um narenjano um Pearl walking around
with the sledgehammer of Truth Damian
Wade passport Bros Zach Box Toronto in
the house showing love Pearl is facts
you know more silly sausage strong and
independent is just being able to pay
for yourself so tell me you're not
homeless okay good for you that is not
something to brag about that's the mere
minimum again guys like the video I
think there's like three almost three
thousand at one point of you in here and
I I think let's get to 2000 likes come
on come on
um Rob Burris um Pearl you need to do a
recap on the engagement ring girl I'm
betting a hundred dollars to show she
isn't engaged with an eight carat ring I
don't think she would do a video with me
at this point I'm gonna be honest I'm
gonna be I've done a lot of reactions
today
okay uh
um okay Brett Cormier interesting that
life gets easier with the more mental
illness is diagnosed when life was hard
and people were struggling just to stay
alive day after day they didn't have
time for these mental illnesses
um Darius and gaming I think my girl was
ashamed to ask me to help her out her
great fantasies honestly I was a bit
turned off at first but now I enjoy just
the same oh god
um silly I read that one already so
um I think I think we lost both of the
girls yeah but why don't you guys say
any final thoughts that you have your
final thoughts man uh and if you learned
anything today yeah kind of I mean yeah
I think I can just go final force which
is I think men we should continue to be
men women can continue to be women
there's nothing wrong with it it's it's
who we are
um we can work together man we can work
together
um stop trying to trying to be the same
I think man I think Mr trying to the
feminist movement we all know how we
feel about that so will the Sheep yeah
so I mean yeah just keep doing you man
let's work together this this
um
final thoughts honestly
um touching on the the more mental
illnesses we uh we create the worse it
is for society just as I think the more
uh like [ __ ] power power we give words
is the word for society such as the word
[ __ ] I got called a misogynist the
other day for calling someone a [ __ ]
she was definitely a [ __ ] you're just
speaking fast yeah exactly but I got
called a misogynist and put on a
Snapchat story called out and you know
how all these women be yeah they're like
oh this guy's a dick yeah
we're not exempt yeah sure it's like
what is going on so like you're saying
the word [ __ ] is misogynistic now like
you just you're just making it like
easier for people to become like you
know to be offensive like you're giving
people power to do that and it's like
along the similar lines with having more
mental illnesses in the world the more
you have of these hateful World words
are are um mental illnesses the more
power you give these things the worse it
is for society and I think we need to
stop being bossies I think we need to
accept accountability
and if you really do need therapy
because there is some people out there
that do then go get it
and better yourself
and that's my final thoughts ladies and
gentlemen well thank you guys for coming
um guys don't forget we are we have a
week off of shows so we are moving
um right after this show we're gonna
start packing up equipment and [ __ ] so
this is our last show here um week off
next Wednesday is going to be our first
show back so tune in then and if you
want to see the new apartment it is so
lit get that 10 a month tier for our
behind the scenes Vlog Jess you already
started filming it right I heard you
yesterday yeah she's she's not she's not
um also go subscribe to our Clips
Channel um we're at about 25 000 Subs we
would really like to get to 50. uh on
top of that sign up for memberships
follow my Instagram guys go tell off the
whales in my comment section they're so
mad they're so triggered just do it yeah
yeah just dot pearly things thank you to
Our member of the week ATA and DM Eddie
if you want to get on the show like the
video on your way out we will talk to
you next next time
peace
[Music]
sweet